[Applause]
oh you can perfect
[Music]
yo what's up guys I am Thomas tobacco
whatever you want to call me we are back
on the dope as usual podcast I am with
my co-host Marty O'Neal what's up guys
what up how you doing how's it going I
hope everybody's having a great day if
you are driving please be safe if you
are at school or at work
you know be cautious don't get in
trouble watching our show and or
listening to our show while at work and
if you're boxing up boxes at a factory
you can listen to whatever you want and
we're here to pass the time I get a lot
of people like y'all just put the earbud
in and I'm working perfect so we always
want all right thank you guys so much
this is Marty O'Neill I am Thomas we are
here for the dope as usual podcast right
now rare Saturday morning filming
I'm feeling great right now I love a
Saturday morning I I guess I don't know
there's no more cartoons for me like
that nah man we got the bills today we
got the UFC today Natalie tonight you
know I'm feeling pretty good about today
about Edibles yesterday so I mean I'm
looking forward to that
I don't know
I just saw that like oh that sounds
behind I bottom I remember the brand I
mean like what are they oh they're kind
of they're no no they're like uh taffies
oh [__] I don't have anything to do uh
my back's getting better so you've been
working on your back all week all week
intense
two a days at the two doctors yeah
uh through my back hey you guys know my
back sucks I threw my back out fully
the week of Will Sasso episode I was in
bed for like four four days five days
um yeah I got an MRI a couple days ago
and they're gonna give me my results
Monday and I went on this medieval
torture device and they stretched my
body
I'm gonna be six foot in this much for
real watch watch I'm like damn that's
your true height does Twitter ever
suggest you like worst punishments of
all time no no they just showed me
fights ignorant stuff
and people doing stupid [__]
I wake up in the morning I'm looking at
Twitter first thing and should check and
[__] first thing I'm seeing is dude get
sawed down the middle in half diagrams
from the Medieval Times okay
that's just scary
no they put me in this box like this
jacket and they strapped this hook to me
and then they stretched my lower body
only
okay
but it wasn't like uh my dessert my
discs are bulging they said so I had to
get the pressure off for my disc to go
back it didn't feel good
it didn't hurt the way you described it
to me it was yeah after I got off uh it
definitely hurt
yeah my muscles were ripping because
yeah they weren't able to move and so on
oh but I'm getting better guys I'm
getting better I want to be able to do a
backflip and land with my fist down
yeah
exactly like a Power Ranger that's all
I've ever wanted
ever since the Power Rangers came out I
got home I think it was second grade I
got home threw my backpack directly on
the ground because that's what you do
I put the TV on and it's like a new show
coming on and I had a guy's face in a
tube Rangers
um what is this and then Billy was all
smart and like I think he's a computer
talking to Alpha and I was hooked
Power Ranger fan that day
I remember it was Power Rangers had the
the putty the gray guys
of course okay because I remember
painting a couple of my other toys gray
a couple of those monsters were Brian
Cranston I don't know if anybody knows
that Brian crash they got his acting
start on the Power Rangers he's a lot of
those monsters I'm not kidding I'm not
kidding at all probably cranston's a
couple young Bryan Cranston yeah he's a
couple of the the monsters on Power
Rangers wow
more you know folks crazy it'll be
awesome if I if I forgot and remembered
wrong and it wasn't but I'm positive
it's Brian Cranston yeah look at that we
have the power of the internet
I'm almost 99.9 sure it's him Brian
Krantz and Power Rangers I think he had
something to do with the newest one
right
yeah
there he is yeah he was a new guy
wow look at him
that's why he was part of the new one
wow all right
meet him on the show oh one day I'm only
going to talk about Malcolm in the
Middle only we're only gonna talk about
Malcolm middle and his appearances on
Seinfeld that's it
no what have you been doing since
Seinfeld someone to ask him Max
that way what have you you've been
writing a lot that's something to ask
him oh
yeah
like breaking I heard a show Breaking
Bad have you seen it
can't wait to tell celebrities I don't
know anything about them that's the new
tactic in uh season four and act like we
don't know what the [__] going on
right
Malcolm's dad right yeah that's it you
played a dentist on Seinfeld right
that's it
um let's go let's continue guys let's
continue on to what we're uh doing today
and that's talking so we can just keep
going here we go
um like I said if you're driving be safe
I Marty has been going hard on our
social medias lately and I've been
seeing a lot of old clips I forget about
a lot of the stuff we say and I'm
watching like
Dave you said that oh [__]
guys uh let's get into this okay so do
us a favor over the screen boom that is
our Facebook adobe's usual Facebook 70
000 [__] new followers
two months let's go just started it just
started oh one thing I noticed there's
some monsters on Facebook
oh my God the part of me and your
children's children will be hooked on
meth oh my God it was a joke and I got
about
75 people telling me that addiction is
not funny it is hilarious depending on
how you say it like there's a guy
tweaking on the ground oh he's addicted
that was so sad is Mom's looking for him
is awful oh that tweaker just [__]
said something hilarious while tweaking
on the ground like yo
and she had an intellectual
conversation with me she was battling me
with wit and then she had an epiphany
went
it stinks
I don't have shoes on and also if I cut
up a nice Cliffhanger that makes you
want to watch the episode that's what
it's [__] supposed to say it's
supposed to do because we did the step
down episode
wow there's like 700 000 views and 200
comments of people I will never watch
this piece of [__] show [__] this show
so many I guess I say saying so much
because
I'm trying to dial it back a little bit
while still emphasizing my expressions
yeah yeah sometimes I like to cut a nice
Cliffhanger to get you to go watch this
episode in that case we still didn't
show the picture in the episode but we
could have
Pete still got upset they were so up so
upset but it's okay it's Facebook it's a
different crowd it's new people oh yeah
a lot of new people God people that have
never come across the way we speak guys
our Facebook is like
the public school delinquent just got
put into a private school yeah it is
kind of like and everybody's looking at
him like the [__] the [__] wrong with
you
you don't have both parents
you know addiction's not funny right
like sure you ever seen a crackhead
dance I think it's [__]
um yeah so Facebook's insane they they a
lot of people don't like us but it's
funny to me okay
um
continue boom over our screen tick tock
tick tock's doing great tick tock's
doing really good Mario's crushing these
clips it looks awesome
um also another big thing boom over the
screen that's our Instagram all right go
follow our Instagram we finally got
verified which is insane to me we're
verified all right we're posting every
day on Instagram we're reaching millions
of people every month on Instagram make
sure you're following it behind the
scenes exclusive [__] all day long yes
so we're just busting this little social
media plug real quick also we decided to
start the dope as usual podcast Clips
Channel up again
this is what happened we had 70 almost
60 000 subscribers we're getting
monetization a lot of views
and then we got demonetized and the
demonetization said hey take down all
the videos that could be deemed not
Community friendly
and we'll monetize you again and then we
were like all right YouTube
thanks
took them all down they went great now
you need all watch time again because
you don't have any watch time they're
like [__] they did do us dude
they went here you can have it and
remember in Jumanji where he handed the
dice to the girl you should want a place
I'd give him back anyway
she played that's what they did to us
sorry that's exactly what they did to us
dude
we have
five something million watch time hours
we only need three thousand let's cry
man but it is grimy it's giving us a
nice good reason to drop all these clips
from I went back to the start when I was
like okay cool this is my new priority
now I'm gonna do this I went back to
episodes one two three started chopping
those up first
so if you're a new fan of the podcast
but there's so many great moments it's
fun to go back I'm enjoying this I just
think it's funny
private your videos take them all off
oh you don't have any videos up how can
I monetize it
[__] you I've ever seen in my life but
it's working yeah it's working and I got
a lot of people like damn you guys don't
need to get some new guests [__] this
show like this is Josh Wolf episode from
episode one sir
calm down like damn you just nothing but
the same gas
it's a clip
it says a year ago on it
it's okay some people just don't read
all the way
um that's all of our stuff that we got
going we're pumping out Clips not to
mention the [__] brand new oh
broadcast.com dope as usual
podcast.com go check our new website
that this guy just built it's badass
it's sick it's awesome it has everything
you possibly need also we have fully
opened up 420 sponsors and this episode
is brought to you by raw papers
oh thank you Josh Josh is fully fully uh
sponging the show now so that's you know
what that being said let's let's go
that's something that we'll feel really
good about I'm proud of feels right
I just think it's awesome because Marty
and I like
from what he was doing what I was doing
we're doing all our [__] and then it's
like sir what do you guys get paid to
get high on the show and I'm like yeah
yeah we do which is unbelievable to me
Uncle John be losing his mind you ready
let's get into this guys hey remember
when we had will Sasson on the [__]
podcast by the way and then he got high
last week remember Willis also smoked on
a podcast for the first time ever last
week ever ever in life
I was shocked I was like got butterflies
when I saw that [__] he's like you know
what I'm chilling I'll take a tooth
you're Canadian I love him what a nice
man
guys that was how crazy I haven't rolled
on here I've been listening to him since
probably
10 years it's so many countless laughs
it was so cool to have them on here and
just
it got Shadow Man a little but every
comment is I think this might be my
favorite episode
it was just it was I was hoping and as
it should be because like people aren't
familiar with him but they they weren't
tuned into all the destruction he did on
that whole wave of podcasting before
he's a monster that's why we titled the
funniest human alive because I mean
powerful pound he's [__] up there a
lot of people a lot of people in that
Contender I don't think a lot of them
can do what he did
funny man like unbelievable guys let's
step up the [__] energy out
here
got a story to tell
my many stories but I was gonna do a
story time on this topic I'm like you
know let me just just bring it over here
all right here we go
a little story time coming in
we'll skip around
as you guys know my entire family in
Merced the Mexican side they're all
truck drivers you guys know that I don't
know if I mentioned it but the first
time I ever drove the truck by myself
I've been driving my whole life diesels
diesels are harder to drive you have to
downshift there's eight gears it's a
little different right
eight and up if you have the switch you
can go
all the way up more
um
my dad's not responsible my dad is was a
child when you had me so here's a little
four or five-year-old me my dad's 23
right I'm gonna be 24. and my dad works
he's 13 driving trucks 14.
so what happens I just sit in my dad's
lap all the time and I steer the I steer
the the steering wheel I'm a child I
want to pull get a horn I want to do all
that [__] you know when you're a kid and
the truck driver goes by and you go and
make do it imagine being able to do it
for another kid
I see kids do I go yeah I'd pull it
thinking I'm the man because they're
looking at me like that's a kid in there
um so what happened was
my dad like always said on his lap
always said on his lap
I think I was six years old
I've drove the truck by myself on dirt
roads you know where there's not traffic
not on a main freeway
in California so my dad's like you know
what there's still drugs in my brain
this is a good idea hey son you're five
maybe six Drive the diesel alone
so my dad we're going down 99 going
toward L.A probably close to Bakersfield
there's other humans on the road
all right other people it's the day
my dad says Thomas I think you do it by
yourself and I went really
and my dad slipped off stood in the
middle
held the steering wheel and then I got
in this driver's seat then he sat like
ass on the passenger seat but looking
toward me in case something happened you
can like reach over
only for the first couple minutes like
he let me do it so here we go I'm
driving I got my foot on the Gap he has
the the the speed set but I have my foot
in the gas like all right cool I got
this and I'm just he's like stay in the
lines stay in the lines what's that sign
say and I read it that's how I learned
to read and tell you that my dad made me
read every single sign that we saw on
the road that's how I learned I I was
reading everything out like three
my dad the speed limit says there speed
limit says that and I used to be a
stickler by slow down so you're just
[__] sitting there and he Springs at
this on you basically I always drive on
his lap but this time he's like you can
do by yourself and I was like okay oh my
God so I'm driving I have my foot on the
gas and then he he we're not shifting
we're just traveling going like 50 55.
I have my hand on the shifter I'm like
oh my God like I'm doing this I have my
hand
a little you know a little me my dad's
couldn't be further than you right there
was no phones you could just be spaced
out on he's watching the road with me
and I'm driving I'm driving and I
remember I hit a little
and I correct myself
and I'm driving and I remember I looked
down and there's like older dudes in a
truck
looking at me and I look at him and I'm
driving and my dad looks looks over and
and the guy just drives off like speeds
past I think I mean I would have been
like is that a child driving a diesel
diesel
but then I think he saw my dad was like
oh still
yeah so I'm driving and I'm thinking
this is the one time I've only had a few
times in my my life where I thought this
and I was like
I could kill everybody on the road right
now this is very scary like if I just do
this because I want to oh you are dead
I remember my dad gave me a gun I was
like nine and he let me shoot and I had
in my hand like
if I want to I could shoot all of you
this is not what I want around Mrs scary
but that was the first time I ever
thought like I can kill you guys I don't
like this feeling anyway we're driving
he let me drive like 15 minutes and then
that was it too much responsibility for
a child it was too much it was it was on
my brain like I really like oh well I
Could Just Kill You
I don't want to do that
agreed I don't want that around you know
what I'm saying like I don't want that
that's supposed to be having to make
that decision at that age
dope
but I was driving so I was like five
years old
they let me start taking the truck by
myself right yeah all I'm saying that is
I know but I was way different than Emmy
Emmy is a very childlike child I was not
um I was like seven maybe
nine when they started let me drive the
truck by myself but on the property
you know I mean like
it's only uh 90 yards I'm
going slow down here yeah like reversing
just in the Rocks doing circles April
stop that lets cam Drive the tractor and
[__] kind of like that
yeah there you go when I got to like 11
or 12 is when I was like
they're all work
I'm gonna take the truck down the road
and I would take the truck to one down
the road there's one right turn off
Belcher and I'd flip around and come
back because it got a big ass no no
pickups hiccups I wouldn't take the
Diesels this is just too hard yeah
they're just too hard to work with you
you can't go fast there's a lot of pick
up I mean it's like boring so
yeah I was driving I was a kid and um
yeah so this brings me to another
another thing all my families are truck
drivers right everyone
even my mom was a truck driver and my
uncle Jaime's wife was a truck driver my
uncle homie let's just start let's do
this
my uncle had me marry this lady this
white lady she was very cool to me
very awful to my cousins right didn't
know that until I was older
um I remember this and I was
22nd Street remember when I said I saw
my stepdad and he was showing a bunch of
tweakers how to fix a car across the
street my uncle's Apartments I said
these are the apartments
I'm in the apartments with my dad my
sister my cousin and we're watching the
news
and on the news it was my aunt Tanya
the one that that's our house I'm in
like you're on the news somebody ran her
off the road she was driving a diesel a
young white girl like this is 1994.
young white chick with like curly hair
somebody ran her off the road in her
diesel
other diesel like hit and ran her off
the road like on purpose yeah
you know what she's wild she might be
lying but this would happen her truck
started flipping and I remember
she was on the on the news for like
surviving this crash or whatever but she
like Snapped her leg in hella places and
[__] and I remember thinking
so you can get really hurt driving and
that's like the consequences of driving
kind of hit my life and then
I remember somebody drove my Grandma
Grace off the road Jesus Christ yeah
when I was like 12 somebody ran my
grandma off the road into a canal
right they had some road rage yeah but
he was in a diesel also
okay I don't know I think what it is a
lot of two years are up late I have a
lot of tweakers a lot of truck drivers
are up late they start tweaking at least
in the valley and maybe they went nuts
and like oh we're just trying to rob me
or start tripping I mean dude come on
and then I remember I was with my dad
and my sister I was probably about 10.
and we were trying we're on the 99
coming to Merced and a diesel just does
this
tries to run us off the road as we're
coming up on this
and my dad is break and then every time
we try to do it he would do it again and
every time we got close he would try to
run us off the road and then we got next
to him he was just completely normal
the [__] tweaking
I do a bit dude
um but truck driver life is weird I
think we talked about the CB radio we
mess with everybody on the CB radios a
lot
um
what our thing was we would tell stupid
jokes and other truckers are adults and
they have jokes so me and strange it was
non-stop entertainment I don't know how
the shirt works but if the guy's being a
dick and he's right next to you can you
like radio at him 100 my dad has yelled
at fools on CBS a hell of [__] but you
gotta be on the same channel
it's different it's different a lot of
banging goes down on those CBS a lot of
drugs go down on those CB radios oh [__]
okay a lot of code words I'm over here
at the Flying J say some [__] like oh
you got someone that's selling Chris
okay gotcha hook us up Flying J got you
damn it's like a community of fools like
yeah on the road for three weeks anybody
got any ice
they're not really but like that's like
code words yeah Ice Road Truckers is a
whole different statement when it's hot
you know
[__] desert
um
so yeah that happened all that crazy
[__] happened CB radios uh my grandma
got run off of [__] road my mom's got
into a bunch of crazy things truck
driving is very odd truck driving is
weird
um I hate it
it's the most boring thing you could do
I feel like you'd have to be on
something to be able to do that past
once or twice
you know what I've noticed
a lot of black young black dudes young
Arab dudes yeah getting into Trucking a
lot yeah good they're smart it shouldn't
just be
fools that figured it out well that's
what Jamel did when he got out and then
he ended up getting his own truck and
he's probably over 120 beds a year
a lot of you people don't understand
that Trucking is a huge huge industry
you work for yourself
you're responsible and you can make over
100 bands at least a year my dad makes
at least that yeah my whole life though
it has always been working his ass off
my dad works dude
um
and I won't say who but I have a family
member
my dad just called me like two days ago
he's like man I'm done with Trucking he
told me again I have a family member I
won't say who
've been tweaking real hard lately
it's really weird to see
between hard one of my family members
like let him work for one of the
companies
full stole the truck and trailer hmm
stole the whole thing just left
yeah so what do you do they [__]
after they waited like four days and
like we don't want to call the cops
because then that's like a felt like
he's gonna get in trouble
they had to call the cops like four days
later and right when they did they found
his as they're like the truck is dead
that has no gas and he was in the
trailer just tweaking
bro it's so weird because this I won't
put them on blast but he's one of my
family members and I grew like he's
older than me so like he was cool
it's weird seeing this [__] is he like
relapsing or he's a new tweaker relaxing
that's very odd
it's weird seeing that [__]
because I've been around Tweakers my
whole life but seeing like wow dude I
thought you were like your [__] together
yeah like if somebody was like a
responsible adult while you were a kid
and then you grow up and you look at him
you see him like that responsible
multiple States
damn what
what happens to make a adult starts I
don't know that's not fun drugs aren't
fun like that
yeah it doesn't look like you're like
chilling having a good time on that [__]
I don't ever want to be sweaty
just like in my car and frantic yeah
like that's not I'm good
I'm good
um
so yeah damn dude you know I was
thinking the other day I have a lot of
stories and a lot of the stories I'm
like I wonder everything should I not to
hold that story then again it's like
couldn't be more anonymous
say people's names
they're my family
but who I mean who cares
don't do stupid [__] it's right there in
the title of the show
bottom of the website
website looks so nice by the way um
so yeah that's what's been going on
stole that [__] now he's in jail got it
we got it all back
but
definitely some crazy [__] he's in
prison over a five day
Bender basically you know what's crazy
is we talked about my stepdad and how he
didn't show the picture and that's my
mom just text me about him
oh really yeah not like he hit her up
with some something adjacent couldn't
show his picture just for [__]
obvious Public Safety I am not privacy
I'd rather stop the show yeah we're not
that's just no because what happens when
something's going down I'm like oh my
God is this because I did that all of
this because of that
I wish I never did a podcast
because if five years look later like yo
remember we used to the show yeah that
was fun but I didn't get killed
yeah yeah so it's just stretch to even
really talk about the [__] so everybody
knows you guys respect that yeah I can't
I can't do it
oh the update uh
my stepdad used to have a best friend
okay dumb remember I told you I slammed
him grown a full-grown man into a oven
this best friend uh we're at his house
I'm like 10.
but I'm like this same thing as a 10
year old just like
hmm
Apple pants to me
a 10 year old passes me insane pants in
it how old was he
dirty
dancing pants don't make you want to
kill a [__]
I remember as I was pulling him up I was
like hmm
I'm gonna get you right now yeah yeah
yeah
you understand what's about to happen
bro like you can't fully hit me my step
dad will kill
you where were you guys in his house
with my stepdad and my stepmom and and I
mean I stepped on my mom my stepdad my
stepdad's best friend his wife their
three friends or another two week homies
like two other homies a bunch of loser
fools drinking beers a bunch of fools
was he trying to be goofy or yeah he was
trying to be funny because he always
[__] with me
open as full pants to me boxers
everything everything I was so mad
I picked him up I looked at him
and I rushed him like Christmas Story
nice yeah I rushed him I picked him up
by his hips and I threw him straight
into the oven
and he was laughing going oh my God
and he was looking at everybody like
what but he's pointing at me and I'm
looking at him and I'm like gonna hit
him and my mom is grabbing me
and I was just like who what what do you
think you are like like I was 20. I was
looking at him like he goes oh my God
and then my stepdad Oh Me Oh damn he's
so strong like shut up
hit your heart I was like do something
oh man anyway that guy texts my mom
today when she texted me I followed you
when you said that
I know but that's what my step takes to
call me only
he would never call me Thomas or
anything it was only that hold on
Ned Flanders
he would never call me anything else
yeah
it was pretty wild
but uh
I guess my stepdad
stole his best friend wife and married
her
and robbed him oh [__] wait like my
stepdad's best friend hit up my mom was
like hey
The Rundown
I've seen you in 19 years but let me
drop some drama on you
Facebook's a wild place there's a lot of
those guys going Egyptian is not a joke
yeah he stole my baby's mom married her
moved into my house and then robbed me
wow all of these things holy [__] like
first off wait you're gonna leave me for
him damn all right let me at least call
home my key doesn't work you guys are in
there oh going back to his car I'm
robbed damn dude what
when you say you robbed them what do you
mean
I went to his house and stole everything
and what are you gonna do about it
and walked out
that's exactly what happened my
stepdad's best friend knows
nose
that's the thing when you're friends
with a [__] psycho things go wrong
psycho but they didn't friends since I
was 10. Oh and before they did that to
him
he doesn't play by rules like that
something happened my step dad's not a
scandalous person something happened
where he felt playing and goes
everything you have is not mine I'm
gonna take your life now that's exactly
what happened like that beard shaving
I'm gonna grow a beard
I grow beers not you I swear to God he's
that
yeah that's a movie yeah it definitely
is that guy
now that I'm older I get it that's it
I'm taking your life
you're gonna kill me no no no like take
your shoes off
literally I won't be sleeping in your
bed everything oh that's perfect
yo that's evil and then you turn back
around and [__]
I want to know how he robbed him
afterwards Jesus Christ my mom even said
how is he gonna steal someone's wife
how does this happen what kind of fight
is this and I'm like Mom he just fights
better
that's it she's a tweaker [__]
she's gonna go well I can have this
white guy with no teeth or this white
guy with no teeth this one could fight
good
so I guess that's it he lives here now
that's all it was on some caveman like
and then runs off like that's something
exactly what happened he said they're
roasting [__] pookies
not Meats
wow yeah
yeah we could demon I get it totally get
it if I get it now understand yeah okay
because you think about other podcasts
yeah they're talking about stuff and
[__]
no one's comparing caveman and Pookie
pipes and meth heads so I get it I'm
trying not to cuss as much it's like
basic human form that we're talking
about he just like it's like when Frank
Gallagher moved into November 100 kind
of like that dude come on Dead on the
thing is it finds what I think is funny
is he's she actually showed me the text
like if he ever shows his face around
here again he doesn't have an accent I
just [__] added it on there
and uh
you better not show us fate but what are
you gonna do
that's like me smacking it peeing on you
and leaving
ten more seconds of that [__] and it
would have been over for Thomas but shut
up
shut up mom my friend was saying that
about yeah he texts my mom if I ever see
him again and shows his face around
these parts
it's [__] eight feet wide you're
gonna see him today
Tweakers you know what's crazy
right now drop it in the comments you
can go across your whole town see people
at the store oh a mom drinking Starbucks
on her phone oh that girl's got big ass
glasses in 2008 oh look at some kids at
the mall where are the Tweakers they're
functioning somewhere there's a place in
every town where you open a nice dorm
like wow someone's son took over this
house
like the owl man just let it go his
tweaker son is running it
Tweakers do [__] in the day but where
are they
it's kind of crazy to think about right
even though you have a nice your nice
house there's twacks there where are
they under bridges yeah they're in the
woods and in the woods
in alleys but there's not really alleys
out here
I think about that all the time like I
remember there was times where I would
be on drugs like doing coke and I think
I wonder what so-and-so's doing right
now and then I think about all the times
where I'm doing something fun and going
there's people right now snorting Chris
for the first time
or like there's somebody right now going
well I'm homeless now [__]
that's weird yeah
especially around here and I think about
it all the time whoa like what am I
doing right now like what's my homie Joe
doing
outside somewhere
doing something weird yeah like these
little things that I'm worried about in
my life I'm over here just chilling
doing this but meanwhile just as I'm
doing this
same [__] reverse I'm 15 me and Jordan
is chilling together
like don't worry in like 15 years oh
drastically different
it's weird I always think of like the
reverse
I remember the day I signed my homie
Anthony's yearbook I'm like for your
future kids man
now I'm like meeting his kids I see him
all the time it's always so weird
I was seeing a butterfly effect [__] and
go yeah what happened what do you think
of that movie all the time what can we
go back I think they help because [__]
this sucks
oh like the last rant City
I said I drove into Merced
right when I got there I went wow I
haven't seen him in a long time America
tweaker frantically riding a bike I
don't know if you guys remember I said
that
this is two weeks ago three weeks ago I
said that
a week and a half ago
so basically a week after I said that
Rosie tells me that that fool died
the person I'm talking about died
we're not old yet yeah
that fool's dad he's in all right
remember in story time where I talk
about I accidentally smoked meth
and I did the reenactment
well remember the original story where I
said I went outside this full Lamont was
smoking cigarettes and he flicked it in
the air
that's who passed away full of months
yeah full from that story time he
probably got hooked that story time that
cabbie
he was probably willingly smoking those
that's sad man it sags I remember he was
just like a slightly older and he could
buy cigarettes for us and he was cool
what about it would have made you want
to go back and do it again anything I
mean nothing that sounded complete
totally horrible what it is I think
would save my life because I'd probably
be a drug addict
is movies
I always see examples of people messing
up and going well don't do something
like that everyone's Scarface was like
no kids like yo you could have caught
him earlier and now look what happened
to you shot the fool in the head now
you're dead and I always think of like
Good Fellas like yo don't go down that
alley those guys are moving boxes he was
going to get you killed go back to Henry
like I oh I talk about all the time I
always say no if this that's what I say
if this is a movie am I the bad guy no
then I'm fine yeah
yeah truly if I'm not the bad guy then
do I care no I'm the right this is a
movie and you're like oh you could be
the dick yeah then you should probably
read things it's a really good way of
thinking about it always in a
relationship if this movie happened you
guys broke up in a relationship who
would the audience be rooting for
all right then
she a [__] or he a dick
title of the episode
[Laughter]
[Music]
I like that
thank you
so
strawberry lemonade by the way I smelled
it I was trying to I was trying to
pinpoint I smelled it that's the way
Widow I love that one the infamous White
Widow hold on
is she a [__] or he a dick leads me in
perfectly into my next topic
and I only wanted to talk about this
because
it's kind of like a soap opera
so when I was in Portland I told you my
uncle
he married my aunt my aunt Tanya that
got her leg broken okay bad person now
she's getting a lot better but there's
very few people I'm like oh you're a bad
person I don't know if I can associate
with you
anyway
my uncle is not a good husband right I
mean I'm not sitting here like damn you
put family business on blast everybody
knows Michael's not a very good guy when
he was younger he's a cheating my aunt a
lot obviously you know he's not a very
great husband and
um I didn't see it happen I just heard
every all the time they were always
fighting and things would happen you
know he
more than once right
so I remember
I remember one time it was a job we get
off a job I think I told you this story
I get off a job and we go to Best Buy my
uncle wants to go to Best Buy to buy
something I'm like okay I'm so polite
I'm so like this is not my house I don't
know like I'm not gonna just like
get water or something you know what I
mean like it's not I'm that person like
hey
no John's always like stop knocking on
my door and walk in and go bro I'm never
gonna just walk in your house ever of
course
it's not gonna happen
so answer the door that's the thing
because he takes forever answer the door
so
a story called you I said I was pulling
up so anyway the reason I say that is
because
my uncle I get in this truck I'm not
gonna it's his [__] I'm not gonna touch
this stuff because I'm gonna go to Best
Buy and he was listening to some music I
didn't want to listen to you got the
keys in the car so
the reason I'm only saying this because
I could see off the rear view me or the
side mirror to the front door and I'm
like okay I'm gonna wash the front door
so when I see him coming I can change
the music back and not be like yeah you
just touching my radio
wow okay he's not going to be like that
but I I'm it's my first time working
with my uncle I'm with him like he's
paying me I'm not trying to touch your
[__] so I keep looking in the side
mirror but the reason I'm saying this
because I keep looking the side mirror
because I want to make sure he's not
coming back I'm like damn what are you
bumping I'll change my radio for that's
the like the anxiety I had like oh man
I'm just trying to do my work and sit
here pretend I'm not here kind of kid
right
but I'm looking inside me I'm like
hey ain't going to Best Buy
so me looking inside me or trying to be
a Vigilant on not being rude I see this
[__] not go to Best Buy and he
gets into a bat into a truck oh [__] I'm
looking I'm like
huh he gets into a truck
what
okay but like four rows down we're like
five rows I'm looking this way because
I'm looking at the side mirror and I'm
watching it I'm like
you gotta do a truck I don't care
I thought nothing of it
I was like maybe I thought it's all
wrong I'm just looking
and I look at the time like
40 minutes
what's going on here
and then like 45 55 almost an hour
I see him walking I'm like oh I changed
the radio back but we're looking for an
hour and I almost missed it he's walking
back up to the moving truck and I change
it
I'm sitting there and he gets in he
looks at me
like what's up
and sorry about that it took forever I'm
like that's cool am I handling where's
your [__] at you what'd you go to Best
Buy for in my head he goes you saw that
right I go
what
he goes don't play dumb you saw that I
go
I just been sitting here
because
all right turns the truck on and we left
I didn't realize he was meeting up with
some [__] to cheat on my aunt with yeah
I didn't know
I didn't realize like oh is that why you
said that like oh you caught me
but anyway the reason I bring that up
is because
my uncle's cool he's just you know he's
that he's one of those guys one of those
guys a scratchy movie to do with a kid
I think he was more like one of these I
saw that right oh it was like that oh
Jesus Christ it was kind of one of my
uncle's like but he's cool he's just one
of those dudes man he's one of those
guys I remember when I was a kid he's
like if you don't have sex with 100
girls by time you're out of high school
what are you doing
not having kids bro
I remember he said that to me and I went
there's only like five girls that I
would like want to date at school but
what are you doing who are you meeting
this is a small town some of those have
to be a cousin like just by averaging
just by averages and it was the 80s and
90s like dude there was a lot less
people back then
anyway I heard him say that when I was a
kid I went oh
God that's disgusting I was like seventh
grade when I heard it anyway fast
forward you see that huh I was like damn
and I I don't mean to like I don't hope
he doesn't get upset that I'm telling
the story I'm gonna [__] tell it just
don't watch then but I hope you don't
get upset at me telling the story of my
family members watch but look what he's
saying about I ain't saying nothing that
nobody already knows it's not like I'm
telling secrets
um but I I will I'm saying the story
because it has I'm only talking about
things that have good endings
not good for everyone but like
all right good movie good movie
um
my aunt Tanya
you know she has like five kids my uncle
my cousin Brina that just graduated high
school my sister my
sister Shireen my sister Grace and my
cousin all went to Miami to hang out my
uncle for the graduation like week after
my sister took him
Mike
my cousin Marina was born and then my
aunt was pregnant two weeks later
okay oh yeah
that was fast
Jesus Christ so the reason I'm saying
this is she had kid after kid after kid
after kid after kid after kid so she
used to be like very like in shape lady
and now she's not she's a very she's
like a bigger lady so I think she was
feeling like a little like I don't feel
like myself and I know this Fool's
messing around on me but my homie was
Ballin so we had the moving moving
company that was like a ninth in America
all that crazy stuff the Oregon moving
stories and all the crazy houses like
this is the time like balling
so I think they were just busy running
running businesses and like
what is this fool doing oh [__] I have
eight kids uh back to this you know what
I mean one of those classic stories of
like just being too busy and not paying
attention right
so the reason I bring this up
because there was this dude
I won't say his name let's call him
let's call him w
it's called W because I don't know if
they really want me to say everything
like that it's crazy
this guy named W
and he was like a hood not a hood dude
he he was like uh
I Wanna Be Hood but I'm also a nerd
he's like one of those black dudes like
oh yeah my cousins are down so I'm down
but he really wasn't down okay one of
those guys that like stood in the back
of the fight yo we messed them up man
you know you know what I mean yeah you
know a lot of them okay you know a lot
of them
so it's like yeah you weren't even
fighting why are you
I guess if this is Instagram they
definitely be flexing a gun that has
never been shot I could bring up some
pictures right now okay so this was one
of these guys and he was one of my
uncle's workers
so he worked for my uncle as a mover
I work for my uncle as a mover so I
worked with this man
very lazy man
very lazy you know those Walmart work
workers that's like
kind of out of shape dude on his phone
while you're trying to ask a question
one of those workers like yo you are
making us look stupid get off your phone
back when there was just texts that
wasn't even like Instagram
t-9ing right now it was bad dude and it
got to the point like bro you are making
you look lazy
all these Mexican dudes are lifting
everything this doesn't look good if a
racist man walks by right now he's gonna
go us I told you like no don't be making
this look like stereotypes out here fool
like get off your phone all the time oh
I'm like yo you gotta pick your you got
to pick up your pants we're on the job
man we're walking through someone's home
we had a five-star rating ninth in
America
you can't be sagging fool my cousin sags
but not at work we can't we just can't
you can't nice houses don't like that
homeowners don't like to see that [__]
we have held the [__] hood ass fools
that worked for us but like everyone was
like were at work because you get tipped
after two don't be looking like a hood
ass dummy on your phone while you're
carrying boxes in full loud conversation
as he's carrying boxes in and it would
drive me and if you're ignorant on top
of it because I used to be in the office
in my [__] Dickies and 3xyts and
Tim's and [__] [__] with the customer
service yeah yeah but you got to put on
a little hat yeah you have to
but that was the one thing me and him
always get into but hey how about I take
the box down and you walk it upstairs
I'm doing this for two hours I'm I've
been taken up and you've been on the
phone
putting boxes at the edge of a truck he
was just like always the dude trying his
best to not work
always this [__] anyway we got
into it a lot and the reason I bring up
all those flaws is because everyone
talks about him to his face
but hurry up man like everyone talks
[__] everyone my Uncle Jaime and him are
homies though like he's just my uncle
I'm his friend so he never fired him
never like reprimanded him nothing never
nothing ever happened to this guy never
got in trouble nothing
but it was my uncle's like homie and the
one thing is he's like
when I say he's kind of like a nerd kind
of dude so he's kind of like one of
those gamer dudes that kind of like hey
if we can take a shower
but he was mad [__] like he was always
fun trying to be funny
but also like full shut up you ain't
[__] boxer shooting nobody shut up
I'm I'm 14. who are you trying to
impress it's just me and you
like it's just me and you on this job
and you're over here talking about [__]
you did you're 25 years old you're
[__] PTSD with the show yeah but
you're like I'm a child like bro who are
you trying to impress
but the thing is he would be talking
[__] about my Uncle Jaime oh okay and
then when my Uncle Jaime and when he
wasn't when Debbie wasn't there he'd be
talking [__] about him so they're like a
friendship but also like a battle
between them too yeah
so I was in the middle like yeah yeah
he's lazy I know he's lazy I work with
him get him in trouble stop complaining
tell him and then he'd be like your
uncle over there being greedy like it's
his business yeah you're gonna get a
minimum wage or not yeah you're just
gonna get your wage you think you're
gonna get part of the job make your own
company stupid man McDonald's you need
to cut me in on this burger sales like
you just work here what's wrong with you
he would always like
big ass house and [__] can't even kick
us down like kick you down he's paying
you what's wrong with you so it was
always me in the middle of just hearing
that like yeah he's lazy yeah he's
greedy
but only me and my head going he's not
greedy he's just doing his business and
you're lazy as [__] I've told you to
your face 82 times please get off your
phone the reason I'm saying this is kind
of stinky kind of a loser doesn't work
hard kind of lame thinks he's tough
and then my uncle and Aunt separate
right
who moves right into my uncle's house
W Jesus Christ not with my aunt
so grimy
could you imagine
bro he was in my uncle's house
living there
quit completely quit
so as my ads doing all the calls and
work they still work there no he quit my
uncle's spot moved into his home because
my uncle didn't live there at the time
because he moved out because they're
separated
W moves right in starts banging my aunt
and they're together now
gets divorced she keeps the business
he now owns my uncle's business he owns
the whole thing essentially because my
aunt's one of those dumb [__] is like
yeah you're better with money you can
make it you do it she's like one of
those [__] that definitely like if a
pimp got close to you you better hold on
tight because you're leaving with him
you're dumb
oh give me that 20 I'll turn into 70.
here it didn't work can you give me
another 20. here every day
so he
he's running my uncle's business now
he's like uh like he full ownership what
was it I want to take your life yeah
what are we talking about yeah he took
his Essence he took it off from [__]
nut Flanders yes yes I'm gonna take your
whole life your life is mine now wow two
guys in the same [__] episode doing
this [__] that's crazy he went and
started dating here who are these
[__] that are just going for the best
friends they're [__] split up he was
working for the moving company up until
moving in while my uncle's on jobs I
think he was having an affair with my
aunt of course I mean he had to be but
he was like calling off work when he
should have been working with my uncle's
like no I'm gonna call off work today
I'm gonna go bang your wife while you're
at work
short-handed
the most diabolical [__] I've ever heard
insane insane but also the reason I led
with
you know
both of you guys aren't very good in
this marriage
you know it's not all her fault she just
did what you did
way more devious
but the Act was the same to cheating and
having an Affairs you've Fallen like was
did he plot okay
okay not done all right rest in peace
Jerry Springer oh [__]
yeah this is exactly Jerry Springer but
real live and I watched it unfold like
oh my God that stinky ass fool anyway
divorce my aunt keeps the company ninth
in America
the company with this man like on a
technicality type [__] well when they
were splitting everything he's like well
you keep that then I'll keep this you
keep that I'll keep this
wow bro
the man went from complaining about
being they oh he didn't share nothing to
it's my the Yelp ever is mine he took
the business essentially with my aunt
wrote off into the [__] Sunset to the
bank crashed it into the ground in three
months of course all reviews went to
[__]
so bad that she sold the trucks and
stopped doing everything wow
Jesus [__] Christ why would she even
want that
it's making so much money yeah I want
the business it's making money because
all of his family members are running it
we no longer run it you're a [__]
dumb hood ass boyfriends running it with
his homies going nice TV
on the phone yeah where you want the TV
no no we don't no you'll be moving
he was one of those dudes like bro why
are you here Uncle why why do you keep
him here he is dumb
you know what I mean not me just dumb
and ignorant
your wife
Jesus but that's how that story played
out man
oh an evil and devious man crazy how
[__] turns like that I wonder if you
just fell into that or if he really no
no he just fell into it he was hanging
out at the house all the time after work
we'd all be sitting there and hang out
with the kids I've been chilling with
them he was still fun he's like
no he'd be sitting there while
everybody's adding up the numbers get uh
taking the stuff out the truck
everybody's getting back into their
trucks getting paid he'd be like what's
up what's up what's up he was a younger
dude
all the kids my cousin Adrian was my age
so we'd be like what's up fool W what's
up what's going on but in our heads like
I wish you would work better because
you're cool I just wish you would work
harder because you make me hate you
because I'm doing your work
you know I mean like I If you don't do
it I'm doing it
did you see the episode of Black Mirror
where uh the two dudes are up on space
and they have like body doubles down on
Earth
there's two dudes working on a spaceship
up in space
but they have body doubles on Earth that
they can like Avatar Style they lay down
in a tube and that's so scary
they're up there on Earth but then
something happens uh and the one dude
can't come back down to his body so like
his family gets killed so the dude's
like you can use my body you can go like
if you you want to do you want to paint
you're a painter you can go paint at my
house so the dude you know teleports
down to his house it ends up trying to
take his wife and his life just like
this [__] foreign
Black Mirror
Moving services
Black Mirror Moving services
that's exactly what happened [__] oh and
then um
she lost the house
and then they broke up
he essentially sold off all her all of
her stuff
damn
so he just had a this is like oh he
probably still has a couple dollars from
it yeah
there's my uncle going
W's took half of my [__]
because she doesn't have it he has it
did you ever get his thoughts on all
this [__] no well I only lived a little
like a couple blocks away never went
back over
um no [__] no
and that's not why my aunt's a bad
person that's fine that's not even why
she's a bad person at all if you think
that's why no no no no that's that's
we're not judgmental here yeah nothing
bad not harsh the other shouting won't
get into because that's getting into
some [__] she's a bad person
that's it wow but
gotcha [__] that's what he did to her
that's exactly what he did do for her
dude
he did this like what camera's doing
he did that to her but in all reality
that's him over there on the wall Homer
Simpson
damn
yo what's up guys super stoked and happy
and proud and excited to be announcing
this new sponsor this is raw rolling
papers thank you so much to Raw thank
you to all the fans thank you to Josh
for looking at the show and going no
that's what I want to support that's
where I want to sponsor so we appreciate
it raw does not sell direct to Consumer
you cannot go to a raw website and go
let me get a pack of papers hey don't do
that they only do wholesale so you have
to go to your local shop so what we're
doing here on the dope as usual podcast
is just telling you if you're gonna go
smoke some joints if you're gonna go
smoke a paper make it a raw paper Josh I
have said it to him many times he is the
Willy Wonka of the weed Community if
someone's gonna invent something it's
probably Josh I have said so many things
to Josh goes I invented that so right
now go ahead and check out Raw on
Instagram it's raw life247 right here
popping up on the screen the YouTube
channel is raw papers official Josh
thank you so much and above all guys we
have something coming very soon that is
going to be everyone's gonna be excited
so coming soon I'm not sure how but an
RPG style joint coming to the dope as
usual podcast so remember if you're
gonna smoke a joint make it a raw paper
ashtrays tips lighters the coolest
scales you could think of the craziest
trays wooden trays uh trays with your
favorite rappers and artists of all time
raw does everything and anything you can
possibly think of in the Wii community
and they're doing things that they're
inventing thank you guys so much back to
the episode
my uncle's ex-wife did a lot of bad [__]
to where am I gonna I don't like her but
like she's so nice to me yeah and she's
still
this is the problem
she's very very very very nice to me
she's always been so nice to me
genuinely likes me and I like her but
she was extremely mean to my cousin
Adrian remember my uncle went to prison
for beating my cousin Adrian and she's
the one that did it my uncle said that
he did it and then he went to prison so
she wouldn't go damn
she beat him like the color of this wall
bro she should be the [__] out of
anyway she did so bad one time that he
like the teachers were like what what
happened
and then they called the cops and like
no this something no he's almost broken
what's happening anyway
that's not even why she's a bad person
she's bad for that but I'm saying like
later on is when I was like nope I can't
trust you
and uh
anyway
since you know since the divorce and all
that I have other cousins remember my
cousin that one uh
state champion the wrestling kid he's he
was the little kid when all this was
going on he's like hey
so when all this was happening
you know years go by
stuff happens where I'm like whoa I
can't I don't like her
stuff happens things go by
she you know how you hit the punching
bag when you walk into the warehouse
every time
she could be the punching bag at every
event a family wise when she walks
everybody Hey hey shut up shut up shut
up they all grown and they all go
you remember what you did
shut up yeah like no we you could stay
here your grandma know
shut up you have no you're getting you
don't get nothing like they're they're
they all like her but if she was my mom
I I would
no no no I would sweep kick her every
day every day I saw her sweet kick drop
a heel ah run out of her chest like I
hate you sweep kicks are [__]
horrible so the reason I'm saying this
all her kids are like
good with her but they're always they're
also like this
yeah stay back a little I don't trust
you fully but you can come over with the
babies mom be the grandma while I'm here
because I know you're capable of
horrible [__] yes horrible things right
wild [__] this is the same lady that got
the free pizza when the pizza guy died
I tell you that story I told you a story
I talked about it right here I don't
remember that one but maybe
she complained that and I told the story
on Tick Tock and
yo what's crazy is a lot of people
think that my stories aren't real
they're like you got that I've read it
like if you knew how and Thai [__]
computer
to find Reddit threads right you just
watch podcasts for the first time yeah
when I hit my back I watched podcasting
oh we'll get into that too
um like you got that I've read it like
if you
shut the [__] up
when I was in Fresno
we my aunt ordered Pizza Hut
I believe it was pizza it was Pizza Hut
I just remember the sausages that are
circles
Pizza
she ordered hella Pizza
it's like 45 minutes nothing and my
aunt's the lady that will
use a car for six years then go back and
get it but now it's defective I want my
full money back and get it
she has taken things into Walmart with
no receipt and got the money back
that woman she is so she got uh
my she got her sister's kids taken away
from her into her custody
because she's yeah and then she was
getting paid to watch to take care of
the kids
her sister her sister wasn't like
drinking and stuff but like
there was like a CPS reporter or
anything like you just swooped and got
custody and the CPS reports done she got
everything when my uncle and her got
divorced so many I think see I don't
like his too into it but she did some
[__] after that money left she saw she
had the police to confiscate my uncle's
truck during my cousin Adrian's
graduation because she knew nobody would
be at the truck complaining cry to the
cop and said the abusive husband stole
the truck and got the truck made a pink
slip this reminds me of the wife of
Ozark she's insanely good with scamming
yeah yeah she can make paperwork and
crazy [__] she will cry on cue she's
that white white woman yeah
who you
so oh and my mom beat the dog [__] out
of everyone I was a kid so my mom don't
like her at all so here we go
um
45 minutes goes by I'm like yo what's up
with this pizza I'm done playing Crash
Bandicoot I'm I'm hungry like I'm done
and it's at the point where crash is
doing this
dancing when you don't touch the
controller I'm done eating apples with
him I'm over it right now and uh hour
goes by my aunt calls what is going on
she called it 45 minutes also
let me speak to the manager Karen she
pulled the whole thing so sorry you know
it's rain it was raining like crazy so
sorry so sorry I'm like all right an
hour calls I'm like okay I I agree
where's the food at we are in Fresno
it's not big it is big but it's 1996.
98 it's not
it's not like populated yet it is you
know what I'm saying anyway hour 15 goes
by
and my aunt calls again like just
as the person answers just yelling blah
blah blah blah stops
oh
what
well what does that mean for me like
what is my what's that I mean for my
pizzas like I've been waiting here for
this long now
what's going on blah blah blah blah blah
blah I want free P I need I know I need
it to be discounted or I need things to
be sent for free because at this point
and she's just after the long pause and
I was like
you shut up for a second what happened
no no you stopped bitching and you
listened to what happened
my dad's there
she gets off the phone
the pizza guy died on the way to our
house
in a car accident he's dead
their co-worker died
here's it
well what does that mean for me gave it
five seconds
45 minutes later
the most Pizza in the world shows up she
ordered like five pizzas we had stacks
they gave her all the free [__] she
asked for
the look on the fir the person's face
was
blank
summer looked like they still delivered
us still delivered the [__] pizza
made we had to remake everything
obviously
because the guy died with our pizza
bring her the same Pizza could you
imagine
[Music]
remade the food brought it I would think
that my aunt told me that she tells us
like the guy I guess the guy crashed and
he he died
and she kind of like I was like oh what
did you say and remember from that time
to when the pizza other person comes I'm
sitting there like
if I didn't ask for pizza
like if I didn't ask for Pete like what
if we would have waited and asked for
pizza and I'm going through the whole
like OCD [__] in my head like well what
if I just well what if I asked for like
ask for some sodas or something or added
something that would have waited he
probably wouldn't have got hit or what
if we didn't want pizza at all and we
just cooked here or what if we just got
McDonald's like you know I started doing
that [__] I'm like seven eight at the
most and I'm sitting here like he's dead
now like I was tripping dude I was very
sad about of course what like the way
she said he pizza driver died but he
crashed
she went right back to her life now and
I'm sitting there
a little kid just like
Crash Bandicoot without the dancing I
was stuck
and the pizza came
and the driver
or the driver's face
they left
I remember right when I sat down and we
were and then there I was about to eat
the pizza I was looking at it like
this doesn't seem as fun anymore like I
was really excited to eat this and I
just feel kind of weird
and then my uncle Abel came home
we told everybody what happened and they
were just like what the [__] are you
talking about
and then that was it
Jesus my uncle should have known that my
aunt was a bad person right then and
there yeah
he was in prison at the time why
because my aunt beat the dark shadow my
cousin my cousin was with us too
like she was he was still allowed around
her which was insane
it's the same as a camping story
no no it's two years after it was then
it was a camping story or a year after
anyway
yeah she's morphed into a full Evil
movie character throughout the story
here but but that was when I was a child
before Oregon
so when I was in Oregon
I remember one time we were doing
paperwork and my cousin Adrian walked
out the room because it's his mom
essentially
does everything she has like helps he's
nice he's nice yeah
he walked out the room closed the door I
don't know if she fried I was standing
there but you're like God I [__] hate
him that's all she said about him
just to herself
oh God I [__] hate him
and I just stayed kind of quiet
and then she went back to paperwork and
I said something she's like oh yeah so
we're doing this I was like did you know
I was here did you not know I was here
because one's exactly worse than the
other if you did know I was here you're
a monster if you didn't then you're just
being oh bleep that bleep that Marty
believe that because we're definitely
gonna get in trouble I've been trying my
best to not say stuff oh man I did that
I did that once when I was a kid I was
walking down the line I was walking down
the hallway and I said some horrible
[__] to my mom under my breath my dad
was like in the bathroom I was like I
like stopped it's like that yeah buddy
[__] does that yeah
[Laughter]
I was like eight should I can't repeat
on YouTube yeah buddy
oh that means like
yeah buddy
that's the worst that was one of the
most embarrassing moments in life right
there
I don't know if embarrassing is the
right word but just it's embarrassing
yeah
ashamed yeah there you go
I said I was gonna beat Mount to death
I'm sorry
Jesus Christ
um hold on hold on
Pizza kid dies
15 years later bam
they're divorced okay
does all bunch of [__] that I don't want
to talk about because I don't know if
they want me to talk about it did a
bunch of terrible things
horrible [__]
so when they're walking shut up shut up
shut up so when they walk into the party
like hey Mom shut up
that's the vibe I get from them they're
all her kids my cousins are more like
we never forget but you can be yeah it's
weird you can see that like it's it's
great but this is the reason why I'm
saying yeah
because it Adrian that's just that's
like his mom still like yeah he he still
you know Christmas all that [__] he's
and I always tell him like I don't know
how you can do it I wouldn't talk to
anything yeah I wouldn't talk to your
dad I wouldn't because are you in the
right or in the wrong my cousin nice to
somebody that's you know was evil he's
the strongest brain person I've ever met
I would actively be hunting them down
for the type of I don't want to talk
about all of it but I'd be trying to
hunt him down I would hate my mom I
would hate my uncle I'd hate my stepmom
yeah
no death I have to second I got strong
enough
he doesn't he's like get some Christmas
presents and like their Grandma and
Grandpa to his kids all that [__] so
he's very awesome for that
but he's also like shut up shut up
tomb to her like all the other kids are
right because my uncle and them had six
other kids besides my cousin
so at my cousin Angelica's which is her
daughter my cousin Angelica's
baby shower
we're all sitting there
everybody we're talking about my aunt
Tanya gets there
she walks in the backyard
you know the grass cement pathway
Smith steps slips breaks her leg in half
[Laughter]
and nobody helped her oh other kids were
like
all right well I gotta set up inside
legit like compound fracture left
to break your leg just falling while
walking is crazy she like slipped off
and broken
buddy I felt bad after because I saw her
and I went oh she's like kind of crying
like she's hurt I feel bad now I was
laughing she just fell
but now I'm like oh no I feel bad for
you you're hurt even though you're a bad
person it's more like you're still hurt
and your family's not helping you that's
not cool yeah that's sad you you feel
bad no matter what that's why I don't
like it in fights even though someone
tried to rob me or something I'm like I
feel bad for you like I don't want to be
getting in the face either yeah that's
sad so um
all the kids periodically went out there
like yeah right here okay you're okay
and then and then the ambulance got
there and they're like wait she's hurt
not done
the party started while she was in the
backyard
the fully started
for her first grandchild oh no no second
second okay sorry second but uh
she broke her leg
walking into the party
I think it kind of makes like if she had
10 points of evil maybe knocks a couple
off for the kids
and then I went Adrian she really broke
her leg and goes ah
I'll be dealing with that right now
well inside the air-conditioned living
room she outside the backyard window
just broke it
so
um the reason I bring it up is because
they eventually helped her and we had to
help her get on the gurney and then she
got taken to the hospital and then we
did the entire party
the best part was is she set up about 70
of everything went to get something came
back a broken leg
and then everybody just sat at her party
that she put together
but it makes up for like a lot of the
bad I think I gotta be honest does make
up for a lot of the bad
um so yeah that's that's what happened
to my uncle's ex-wife Tanya
now that's funny
um
yeah dude there's a lot of there's a lot
of stories out there there's a lot of
bad stuff that's happened
um
yeah
I don't know if I should go into
everything else but I think that was
pretty much it
also
my little sister
starts college this week next week she
moves to her dorm this weekend
it's crazy it's Saturday
and today's Monday that it drops my
little sister started college today
yeah
nice
Wild
what's she going for
oh she told me like the two things and
oh nursing should be a nurse
she's going for medical
yeah guys I just want to get through
that what are we at right now
you're talking [__] about my family for
an hour and 18 minutes it's insane
cool
that was cool
I have [__] like that in my family too I
was [__] just like
really into that story right there
yeah
yeah I got a wonky ass story a wonky I
like the description go go somebody's
hips are off it kind of it feels like my
bomb threat story a little bit is it
Rhys yeah this was just like this week
what so we got a call from uh my
daughter's principal
like it's like the second day of school
yeah and we get a call from the
principals like we got Ariana down here
for uh uh there was an email that was
sent about a school shooting that we
need to talk to you guys about
not the call we expected whatsoever we
were both like
what'd you say the [__] you talking
about
so
he sends an email that was sent to his
email the assistant principles eat
direct email from Ariana's email
of this giant black dude with this huge
gun
holding an AK-47
that's all it is dudes grown adult
really a creek a weird meme picture okay
huge gut shirtless gun yeah okay
and uh
I I think like the subject to the email
was like
School shoot something with that in the
title like is he bald by chance I don't
know I don't remember I just looked at
it quick it looked like a meme of a
picture okay I think I know you're going
with this continue well this [__] was
just
so now we're like okay she clearly
didn't do this something's
if you're gonna do something
goofy like this you don't email the
principal yeah from your email directly
to the Principal book picture of a guy
danger and she's even acting to the dude
like obviously I didn't do this like
what you're doing anything what do you
let's try to figure this out because he
was like understandably pressing the
[__] out of her
and like trying to get to the bottom of
that [__]
now I'm thinking first of all okay is
the SWAT team about to boot our [__]
door in because like you know they could
like this is there's some key hot words
going down with this [__] email here
and they're calling us pretty pissed off
so come to find out
she was
at a neighboring restaurant to her
school waiting to get picked up after
school and let a kid charge his phone on
her school [__]
laptop that they get
she forgets the kid has the [__]
laptop and gets picked up
immediately because we went back through
it
got the laptop back went back through
the history and watched what happened
the kid logs in and he Google searches
this is what this is what gets me so now
he's got access to her computer
and he's like he Google searches
like do man with gun or like no he
Google searched
fat black dude I think was the search
very specific and then fat black dude
with gun
and then decided to send that to the
principal
so this was like on the Fly decision for
this kid
I'm gonna try to see if I can pop this
goddamn picture up on the screen because
it's almost like the Kevin clock picture
how just shockingly weird it is
same idea with this [__] picture of
this kid
to then censor the principle from her
computer from her computer who is this
kid just a random kid did she see him at
school yeah like a kid that's like I
need to beat his ass
that's that's grounds for getting at
least smacked I'm not saying go hit kids
all right before we continue I'm not
saying go beat up children childhood
children so I'm just saying if I was
under 18 I'd be like hey man I've been
doing that [__] to me but I was like
thinking like
what a weirdo what a weirdo to like what
a weirdo you get a kid's computer and
this is the first thing you think to do
like it's not gonna come back to you
like they're not gonna if they want to
go pull the cameras yeah
I'm kick in your door like what the [__]
if you're gonna do some stupid [__]
don't you normally get something out of
it like or are you just twacked out and
you know you know
he just wanted us to talk about it on
the show
he's a fan he's like how am I going to
give them time like you know I would do
some weird [__] he's just so genius [__]
the show is cracking in her school
that's some [__] fact boom
wow all right I'm thinking about this
different now that's hilarious yo what's
up guys just taking a moment to talk
about one of our brand new sponsors here
on the podcast this is freeze pipe I
know a lot of you are looking at it's
just a regular piece what's the
difference well this is the difference
take this clip off this goes directly
into the freezer no that's not water in
there that's glycerin and it freezes all
the smokers out there you know how dumb
it is when you're sitting there and it
starts to overflow on you get too much
water then you suck it in you figure out
oh yeah the ice melted so never worry
about the ice melting again with the
freeze pipe so introducing for the
freezepipe.com this is the mini bong and
this is the tornado bong remember these
right here go in the freezer not the
whole bong the water will freeze and
your bong will break just the glycerin
tops go in the freezer so right here
this is the mini bong this is the most
portable thing all of this breaks down
into pieces
goes right in there down here you have
the inline perk and above that is the
honeycomb perk up next this right here
guys is the tornado bong this is brand
new and in here it looks like little
shards of glass but it's the actual perk
thank you so much for supporting the
brands that support us I'm gonna rip
this and get back to the episode
what's up guys this ad read is sponsored
by manscape as always go to manscape.com
forward slash Yola to get 20 off plus
free shipping it is the deal of deals if
you've ever been curious about any of it
go ahead and try it out use our code
remember it's 20 off and free shipping
and you're helping the show out we've
talked about this whole summer don't
have a dirty dick all right we've talked
about it for two years don't have dirty
dick and balls your significant other
does not want to see that just keep
yourself tired keep yourself manscaped
ready crop boss if your balls are gross
and sweaty and nasty use the crap been
free balling it all summer how about get
the boxers 2.0 they come in the
performance package 4.0 as we always say
for the other head in your life we have
shampoo two in one conditioner and for
your other head and the other parts of
your body this is the body wash and the
latest and greatest for manscape the
body buffer remember guys manscape is
not just to shave it is every single
thing you can think of for male hygiene
go to manscape.com right now
manscape.com forward slash Yola or Yola
at checkout 20 off plus free shipping
thank you guys so much for supporting us
thank you for watching show back to the
episode on to something new something
that's relevant and not from a childhood
or something
that you know keywords and algorithms
might pick up
let's go ready
I
heard that there was the Barbie movie
I'm like hmm
real life Barbie movie that's kind of
funny I guess what's the concept like
they know that they're toys
okay like Small Soldiers or something
my sister
likes good [__] my sister like good
music for the most part likes good
movies for the most part that I would
agree with
talk to her on Friday hey
what are you doing she's like oh I
wouldn't watch a Barbie movie I'm like
oh how was she goes honestly it was
pretty funny I liked it uh wow I'm like
all right you said enough that's all I
needed to hear I'm going to watch it
that night went to watch it
and I text her
no it's too deep in the text
I text her these words you ready
at about 40 minutes and I text her
what's wrong with you
I've almost left twice this movie sucks
so I had about 40 minutes in I went
okay come on all right come on hurry up
and it's not animated right no it's real
life movies with humans and then I was
like
so if I roll a blade on Venice Beach
wait what is that what
and then and I'm like is this for kids
and then it got to like an empowerment
part and I went this is not for kids is
it
and then
I won't ruin the movie for you it was a
part where a Barbie and Will Ferrell's
and Barbie and Will Ferrell like scary
chair then go ah
in a lit up room
while they're actively running and
looking for each other
so to be scared of the person like yo
found you now whoa but you're looking
for her
and I went oh it's a kids movie
and then it was like wait no it's not a
kid's movie and I went what happened
what am I here and then as I was walking
down the stairs
to leave the theater you know the room
and then go out to the theater hallway I
went I would have rather have been
jogging
and working out that's most things in
life no I hate jogging hurts my back I
would have rather have been jogging than
sitting here
damn I I hated it
I really did not like it at all and I
was very disappointed in it I don't
think I've ever heard you say that about
a movie
I had you know we know why because I had
such high hopes for it I thought it was
gonna be real funny because Ryan
Gosling's the man it's awesome he was
kind of funny in there
uh it was just wasn't what I expected at
all this video I saw some people I
haven't uh watched this yet but I saw
some people coming at Theo about this
clip about Barbie so uh we might watch
it yeah let's do it
have you ever watched Clips on here oh
hey buddy you seen Barbie you've seen
Barbie movie and I said no I haven't
seen it because well I'm an adult male
I'm an adult male and I'm not seeing
Barbie movie because I'll tell you why I
think it is for children or gay children
um or child gays or whatever I don't
know I don't want to offend anybody I do
not know the terminology and it's Barbie
and I'm an adult man so I don't want to
see it look when I was a child if a man
saw barbie movie then your mom was going
to leave that man and that's how you got
a stepdad people were like hey what
happened to your dad well he saw the
Barbie movie and my mom read between the
lines
foreign
that's how I came to see it on Twitter
is because people were mad about it yeah
that's funny stop because the next thing
I was about to talk about
was about his okay not that but ready I
get the back doctor my back doctor's
super cool super nice dude
obviously he he would marry a man he's
into dudes obviously and I'm only saying
obviously by stereotypical traits and
you know
friends my family members people I know
people but oh so you like dudes okay
cool life's experience yeah life
experience all right cool he was super
super tired after my fourth compliment
he gave me I went oh weird like dudes
okay
gotcha common sense told her gotcha and
after I went Rose like I think my doctor
would have tried to have sex with me
Rosie if you weren't he she goes oh God
yeah for sure
he's super cool but I'm not saying like
he was coming on me I'm just like
thank you very nice thank you from yeah
thank you I like my teeth too
shave them down if they've been shaming
it took a little off the tops
no but anyway he was super cool
obviously a little flamboyant right
he brought up the Barbie movie
and you know when you meet somebody new
and you're like
Red Hot Chili Peppers comes on
and both you go oh man I and you're like
is he gonna say hate or love this song
and they're like hey and they go ah
sorry
Ace band you're like oh love them I
don't know if we have to a good start
right now yeah you know what I mean like
that's you ever get that way about a
song or something
so he brought up the Barbie movie and I
went
because she he went how did you like it
I went
should I go in or like are you one of
those fools that just love it
um
I looked at Rosie
I did what any nice person as it went
I just didn't like it as much as I
thought I was gonna like it that's a
good stock answer yeah it's honest
though perfect it's perfect it's like
saying Oh I thought you were sisters
that's your daughter it's the same thing
I'm going oh
yeah cause you never like is he being
serious but if you think that you could
be like oh thank you I thought something
the same thing it's up to your
interpretation but either one's not bad
because technically you still could like
it
nah I just kept it like that he just oh
he went in but he's like
um uh uh whatever Theo said right now I
was like okay I get it I get it like
why why would you know I mean grown
dudes can watch whatever they want but
also if you're like you know the bar
let's go get it
hmm
because if that was if I was a girl that
my boyfriend was like oh my God
[Laughter]
my whole family went without me and they
said there was a lot of dads there and
[__] so
of course there's a lot of dads I was
taking their kids man he's talking about
male adults going by themselves I think
that's what Theo was talking about okay
yeah yeah yeah because he hasn't had
kids my doctor and he's just his
boyfriend he said your mom is going to
leave your dad that's funny that's funny
he's a comedian he's supposed to make
things hilarious and I left that's the
most passion I've ever seen this Theo
speak on something that was funny
funny because he like it's not like he
put that act on and was like wow you're
funny if you just you're yourself and go
hey that was fun it was it I was just
talking uh sick
um that's pretty much a lot of comedians
like oh yeah you're just like a little
sassy but you can say whatever and I
think you're just gonna be funny about
it
um
yes my doctors loved it loved it
um I did I just didn't like it I just
thought it was gonna be funnier
really that's it I thought it was gonna
be funnier so when you make the clip
about the Barbie please put this part in
there too so people just come and try to
stab me
um I just did not think it was that good
uh they got real deep like try to get
deep and I was like hey
do that don't do that don't care about
that I'm here for this fly or something
make a big hand come from the sky and
play with you like as Barbies because I
like roll sasso's poster of the Barbie
show that was cool
all the pair all the clips and
everything I've seen online are great
I'm like yeah that movie okay I'm gonna
go watch that and then I watched it and
then I text and then after I left I went
I don't know if I could trust my
sister's opinion anymore
because don't forcefully say you liked
it because you liked it
just say you like Margot Robbie [__]
just say he thinks he's attractive and
that's why you want to watch it
yeah which made me want to go watch it
too she's awesome she's good in every
movie I've seen her in Ryan Gosling is
awesome also like yo this is perfect
they made a billion dollars already damn
but I get it though every kid in the
world is going to go and go why is it
getting so hard to understand it and the
parents like it's getting deep and
philosophical so I was sitting there
going why
what the [__]
that was it sorry that was my movie
analysis I just I just didn't think it
was gonna I thought it was gonna be way
funnier it wasn't funny
that's it all right that's fair opinion
that's it I saw the uh Ninja Turtles and
luxury in what luxury
I thought you said and mushery well that
too you took my shoes and they washed it
yes
was it the bootleg Camp mushrooms yeah
yeah I like those those are cool
first of all for having you on the show
but second of all for having some cool
little uh [__] shoes some tubes
yeah I dip my toe in the day before with
like two of them and I was like okay
because I'm like there's no way I'm
gonna feel [__] two of them so I just
did two it went about my day I was like
I'm feeling pretty [__] goofy I'm
feeling two of them for sure so then I
think it was like the next day or the
yeah
it took like three of them
uh earlier and then went to it and uh it
was
it wasn't as good as Miles Morales the
uh OG one that's like my favorite
animation up to this point oh oh it's an
animated turtles yeah oh see I I really
don't pay attention well there's so many
different goddamn turtles yeah this
one's animated the style animation was
pretty cool I didn't like it as much as
the Miles Morales one but I was noticing
a lot of little [__] my new details
in the animations like
I just think it's really awesome that
you could just like yeah I took
mushrooms
my children had no idea that I was in
mushrooms but you know we were in the
theater
yeah it looks like yeah it was you know
a nice light thing
I don't know if I'd really fully
recommend you go spend two hours on the
turtles but it wasn't bad
I like animated movies when they really
hit this one was cool Ice Cube's
character was the [__] he didn't come in
until kind of late in the movie I really
liked him hmm
I don't know there's not a big animation
fan anymore unless it's like some Pixar
[__] because they always have six
stories yeah I don't follow the [__]
storyline I'm looking at the animation
I'm working at the cool glowy effects
for the kids yeah I'm a child I'm a
child when I watch children movies I'm
not even listening
spilling popcorn in the [__] world
yo
the movies I don't know the movies are
just I can't go to a regular movie by
the way I need the full experience in
order to make it make sense
of the Lazy Boy with the waiters what
the hell that's the best part ever yeah
so fun if you didn't know go to lookamc
has them I think what
that's a real thing yeah cinopolis yeah
everything I hear Oculus I always think
of Jessie uh from from Full House
oh Jesse simplynopoulos cassopolisapolis
then I thought of applesauce as a kid
see
stupid stupid dumb thoughts yo it's that
acid for real some [__] dude something's
Katsopolis Cassopolis something dumbass
all right don't be worried about it
don't worry about it
um
yeah I got so lost right now yes I did
the bootleg Kev podcast go check that
out boom over the screen shout out to
Bootleg cab that was fun that was
awesome a little update if you don't
watch that so I'll tell you this I told
you part of it
I've done many story times
all right
every story time happens to me or I
watched it or it happened as I was
watching it happen it's never like so my
friend said you know he saw 50 pounds in
an old man's trunk like this just
doesn't happen I don't do that because
it's not my story
I've done a lot of story times and a lot
a lot of you know what's crazy is when I
hear them back I go
damn I haven't talked that phone forever
and I've it's like I forget I get so
wrapped up watching I'm like damn fool
that was you that was crazy and I think
like oh you've done some stupid [__] in
your life
and yeah I have which is cool
but a lot of people ask like you can
come on before you exaggerating like
nah
foreign
all right if I didn't happen I just
wouldn't do it
because why would I put on something
that didn't really happen
that's the whole point of story times
whereas I'd be having 50 a day I'd have
the biggest views on YouTube I just pump
out 30 a month one a day one story a day
if they weren't real
right be a rapper yeah you're a rapper
at that point put up a mixtape a day
um so the reason I'm saying this is the
only things I've ever said that are not
true in Story Time are some names some
locations
and some uh dates
I have to throw a lot of different dates
out for certain things certain reasons
maybe in the future I'll be able to talk
to you about that but if as of now I
cannot dates I changed 100 for my safety
locations I changed for other people's
safety and names I change for mine and
other people's safety because I don't
want to be saying everything because
people might get very upset
um so the reason I say this is Boom
bootleg have podcast right I go to this
building and I'm like hmm
oh I've never been to this part-time I
don't think okay we're gonna say where
it's at
all right I walk in and I'm like
a sick place man nice
walking in I see and we go in I look in
like
nice
and there's something you know something
in the back your head like
do I see something familiar
don't I
or is my brain wanting me to say yes so
I could think of that
who cares I walk out walk out the first
building walk through the back little
parking lot to the second building I get
to the second parking lot I mean the
parking lot to the second building in
between I look at the fence and the
driveway it's super gated super guarded
like nicely and I go damn nice spot man
he goes yeah thanks man I went wait
stop and my brain always does that stuff
in movies
and you know what I mean like where it
stops to let you think
that's how I think of a lot of things it
just
I stopped went wait
and has went in my brain and went why
have you been in this exact situation
where are you at what were you looking
at what did you say
I was looking this way toward the gate
and I went nope I turned around and went
I've been right here before and I could
see like the screenshot from my what I
remember from this place they went I've
been right here
except there was a giant man with a gun
that's all I ever met there was a huge
I remember that
that give that game I'm I remember the
back of this building except it's
different color
I look at bootleg Kevin I go
I've been here before
as he's walking me to the second
building remember I said man nice spot
he goes yeah man we actually just and
then I went stop
and I went hey I've been here before I
know I have
and he looks at me and goes
Asian guys and packs
and I said yes that's exactly what it is
do you remember the story time or I go
to the
I can't say the name but I go to the
place
that uh
I walk into the giant guard
I walk into the giant guard and the
giant guard like lets me in the giant
Buff Ass Man with a gun he walks Us in
remember I said I walk down the hallway
I'm like oh it's all white walls and
like this place is wild and I walked in
and there was an old Asian man on the
computer smoking a cigarette with 100
different screens on the wall and he had
every pack range you can think of
remember I walked into the Walmart
facile facility
remember this I talked about this on
Story Time a lot of you are like yeah
it's the same building
ridiculous
as I walked in I go but my memories off
and that's when I kind of questioned
myself
like my memories of
that
because war was wider right here
and there was a there was two doors
right there I'm like I could have swore
there was
or though there was a wall there I could
have swore there was a wall inside of a
door
and then where I said I walked he walked
and sit right here your meetings next
and the guy sat us in there had a little
TV that was kind of like I don't think
it was Jerry Springer Maury pretty sure
it's Jerry Springer was playing we're
just like
that's where you buy packs at
this was the bill because bootleg Kev as
we were talking about he goes yeah I had
to move a wall too I'm like that's what
it is because yeah I had to move some
stuff it was a little crowded I'm like
yeah there used to be a huge desk right
there
and they took it out wow
so
it's the same building
the
the uh typing cigarette that's bootleg
kept studio all state-of-the-art studio
all sacred wall Platinum plaques and
sick [__] that used to be where the man
sat with files and the guy would come in
with a cart with all the packs sat there
with the notebook all the screens on the
wall all gone uh the little room next to
it is just Studio as a booth
the uh place where I sat and watched
Jerry Springer
is now a different Studio he rents out
to somebody
uh all the wall the plaques this that
walking down the thing to the left where
I saw the industrial size Drums of packs
where he had metric I got metric ton of
that I got metric ton of that I had two
thousand pounds of that
and then all the cameras were all the
buildings and the back building where we
did the podcast remember we walked
through the building walked through the
back building was the building that I
kept seeing on the camera where I had
all the shelves it was just shelves and
packs perfectly placed hundreds of them
I couldn't believe it was the same place
and as I sit down and do the podcast I'm
just going through my hair going through
my head going through my head like so
that's oh so when I walked in so all
this is the room I couldn't see because
I remember when I walked the building
there's no room that big
that makes sense
and then he said you're the second
person telling me that he said another
guest
is that one guest like came through and
said he bought packs there
and he's like you just confirmed it
right now I was like yeah dude this was
the place like all I hear like this was
the spot because for multiple people
have told me then he said a few people
have gone by asking if it was a weed
shop because I think their front they
put themselves on weed maps as a
dispensary and they never took
themselves off oh Jesus Christ so that
place is still on weedmaster he's like
yeah we had a couple like old people
come in like yo this is a shot like this
is a recording studio can you guys go
away like knocking on the door
like we know this is not on weed match
we're not a dispensary so that reassured
me like so this this really is it's not
my imagination running through so the
reason I say I change locations
sometimes like little things so people
don't remember or people don't know like
I've talked about a story where I talked
about there was metal walls in this
building it was metal and it was wood
but that's a big difference someone goes
oh he ain't talking about us he ain't
talking about that spot yeah for sure
you understand like no all metal walls
and all metal walls with some wood is a
different place so people with the wood
spot are gonna go
well he can't be talking about us then
he said all metal there's a lot of
little things I'm thinking of as I'm
talking about like don't say that yeah
it doesn't change that actually hold on
cut that I'll go Marty can you cut that
cut that say it again because I'm like
no that's too easy to pinpoint and go no
that that's who he's talking about like
I talked about a certain dude that
passed away a huge weed dealer night
it's crazy how many people know each
other
you know what I mean I don't want P even
though the guy's gone I don't want
people like yo when you talk about my
brother's business like that like
hump
turn up Antonio like basically you gotta
shut up but I get it like that's why I
change certain things because I don't
want everybody to be direct but when I
walked outside after I left bootleg have
I go
that's crazy in the in the in the story
time I described the building looking
different I described it a little
different so nobody would ever know
but remember I said it's in the middle
of a dow
yeah when I got back in the car went
it's it's right I've eaten in a
restaurant right there this place was
right here it was right when I moved
right before I moved to LA so
I didn't know L.A well
what are the odds since years more than
almost a decade later
ridiculous crazy that's like that's
almost like that story was that before
the podcast where it's like with our new
brand partner and the new like would you
like hold the door for somebody or some
[__] she's like I work for them
oh yesterday yesterday we have a new
brand partner we're bringing on zodix
all right we'll take it all right thank
you Exotics very much appreciate you
Sonic's we're about to start working
with had a meeting with them a call
yesterday yesterday
at about three
I go see the car or my Monte Carlo I go
check it out 3 30.
drive to a restaurant
eat I'm leaving the restaurant
every time I see someone like driving
like you trying to park
like yo wait I'm leaving right you know
what I mean like trying to help like
I'll help you out because I know how
[__] it is to park over here
and I'm like
hey
no I'm walking into my car
and someone girl pulls up
saying are you guys leaving I'm like
yeah take the spot it's like oh my God
yes she was all high I like you you got
all hyped up and uh
I
open the door for Rosie let her in I'm
gonna open the door she goes hey I love
the videos by the way I went
I started dying like
yeah that's sick thank you and then she
said that so Mike Rosen let me get my
jar so I got some nugs I'm like every
time I see somebody if I have it I'm
like yo here smoke that
so I'm walking up to her car and I go to
like fist bumper all right I go to grab
her so we say oh what's up the fist
bumps been like oh yeah but I was trying
to give you this nugs and she's like oh
thank you she's like hold on I got
something for you I just started working
for some for a brand I'm like really and
she busted the bag out I go
Exotics
just yeah have you heard of it because
yeah I just had a meeting with him an
hour ago she goes for real
yeah sick with Chris with Chris and
Jeanette just had a meeting with them
with my partner she goes wow yeah how
Wild here take the space I felt so bad
taking the week from her I'm like I keep
the wheat like I'm not gonna take your
Exotics bag I'm we're working with him
right now I feel bad like
even though it might be her job to do
but you'll give it to somebody else I'm
gonna have a lot of it like I'll have
weed so I don't want to be like taking
your step but what are the odds of that
that's [__] insane right after the
other
cheers it just happens man in L.A always
10 million people always happens like
that to me I don't think there's really
10 million people
like 20. I don't think there is I think
there's like 30. I'll be driving around
see the same people in the same part of
town bro
what are the or I'll you ever drive like
down Fairfax or Melrose at 11. or three
in the morning and be the only car on
the road I find that very odd that is
like there's millions of people here
where are they like Tweakers they go
somewhere but where are they
behind one door there's 50 000 people in
L.A I guess because
I don't see people walking around I feel
like
at night people are just I think I think
what it was is the pandemic and
everybody's like I'm I like being inside
I think that's what happened because
Hollywood and everything is so dead
right when like 10 o'clock 11 o'clock is
dead really yeah he's like very active I
don't know I don't know I could be wrong
you tell me I haven't lived here first
County's been like that there's not one
different there's not bars there's not
nightlife there's not there is but not
not like what you're thinking no no not
at all
um
damn all we do is talk about a bunch of
sad people's drama today just to
catch-up episodes okay story time it's
okay I feel like
a little lost
little brain [__] maybe oh we have
one more joke
it's a little ass end but she got in
that little ass and the same we've been
smoking the whole time and what's that
lemon poppers
tastes a little different I don't know
why I was like did it nice yeah
um
but yeah guys thank you so much we're
not about done I'm just
say thank you guys so much for being
here if you how long you been here
almost 150. wow this Cruise really flew
by yeah
holy [__] and uh we're supposed to be
this is coming out this is a one day
turnaround episode oh yeah one day we're
supposed to be having an alleged
hurricane so we'll see how that goes oh
yeah
we'll see I hope not
but also Marty we're gonna start doing
it at the beginning of every episode
we're gonna start putting our socials
right before the so before the intro
drops all our social medias and our
number one thing that we're going to
start pushing forever now
go follow us on Spotify even if you get
it for free even the free version of
Spotify please go follow dope as usual
on Spotify we are brand Partners
official brand Partners we are now shows
to watch
coming up very soon are will be on the
front shows to watch upcoming shows
banners on the home page
across the world on Spotify audio ads
and Spotify for podcasters their other
product also they monetize this guys
oh [__] who was it who was it
been surprised evil laugh Jason Ellis
oh also hold on real quick something
really funny Jason Ellis I know he's not
gonna get upset about this is really
funny uh you know Ralph my my cousin
he was on a date he's been on dating
apps right he's single dude he just
moved out to L.A
last night I put an ice bag on my back
and I'm like ow and I was uh smoking a
bowl and Ralph comes up he shows up to
Rosie goes hey
like what what is it because it comes
over to me goes
isn't your homeboy you had on the
podcast They Go whoo and he shows me on
the dating app
and it's chasing Ellis
on the dating app
and Ralph went I put in women only
I put in women why is Jason Ellis on
here obviously Jason is bisexual but it
was the funniest joke is this guy on
your podcast
it is actually Jason Ellis one of the
manliest dudes alive it's just wild that
he went I'm on a dating app and the guy
that you interview song you're like
Jason Alice scared her sick podcaster
what are the odds and she's like a
picture of Jason Ellis that's
it's pretty [__] funny though yeah I
just thought when you just said I just
thought it was just too funny I had to
it's just last night 12 hours ago
that was him when he was like
women's Academy
Jason Ellis you're a menace for that
that was good that was good but yeah it
popped up on his dating app last night I
thought it was a funniest [__] in the
world
what are the odds dating is different
last time I was [__]
[__] didn't exist like people the world
is different imagine dating somebody
through a dating app that's used to just
the world now like I wouldn't even know
how to [__] function it's so crazy is
I'd be doing the same exact thing if I
was single
I'd be feeling the same way and going
I'll get this dumb [__] out here please
start doing Tick Tock dance you gotta
get her out of here
you know what I'm saying like I don't
even know what I would do
see in your eyes disappointment
oh
that'd be [__] weird
that would suck
to be with a girl to end a tick tock
would be [__] real weird not that
like you're into Tick Tock just like
do litter
I don't care what you look like do
litter
you can be really pretty as hell you
just threw your trash out the window get
out of my car
I don't care we've been together for six
months
six months too long [__] get out of my
car
it's just crazy to me it's like there's
little things I'm like we always say
Jerry Seinfeld me Rosie say it all the
time where Jerry Seinfeld I just hate
things we hate uh as I said I said that
too because last night I told Rose this
morning I had a dream a wild nightmare
for like my whole dream last night that
me and Rosie broke up and it was the
worst [__] ever but it was like such a
realistic ass dream and I remember I was
in the dream and I was looking in the
mirror
and I was like what
this is weird and I was like
I did a podcast tomorrow [__]
and it was realistic because I had to
wake up and come to the podcast it was
so real to me it like work that into
your dream your scheduling
yeah
oh it was so weird dude
did you feel relief when you woke up or
was it kind of lingering like
emotion is like all pissed off and sad
my dreams are very realistic it sucks
wild [__] oh speaking of Dreams
did we ever we talked I wanted to talk
about that on the show today
we talked about my dreams on here or was
it just story time I did the dreams
I don't think we have
do we talk do we fully talk about
Rosie's grandpa on here
I don't know anything about them
the war [__] we have to have had we had
to have might have
no
I'm searching my [__] database here I
got nothing all right or dreams you know
Rosie's Grandpa was in World War II and
I had World War II dreams
and then when he was dying we talked
about this stuff or no uh okay well if
you have the best memory I'm sorry if
you if I've talked about on the podcast
before but I woke up this morning
thinking about it I was like yeah I'm
talking about the other show today
there's a lot of story times that I
don't think I've ever put on here and I
know a lot of well we can tell them
story time already seen it not everybody
has watched my channel you know why
because 1.6 million followers on topaz
YOLO would be the same on this channel
if everyone was a fan of both that's
just a fact you know I think like
everybody watching full so
the reason I want to talk about it is
because
I've had very wild dreams my whole life
very Vivid insane dreams
um I think I have the [__] The
Shining uh
I just
I've had a lot of dreams that I that I
see in person I've had a lot of Dreams
where
I feel like it's just a warning or
telling me like yo be very cautious and
I have a photographic memory so with all
that combined
I feel like I've dodged a lot of things
because of Dreams I've had
my Grandma Grace has a book like an old
book in Spanish and tells you what your
dreams mean she's had it my whole life
um
whether or not that book's real or as
accurate is up to you interpretation but
every time she's ever looked in it to
tell me something it's been exactly what
I feel
um she's like yo you're having dreams of
your teeth falling out you ever have
teams of your teeth crunching and
falling out or just something about your
like your whole like your teeth being
broken taken out falling out they're
coming straight out you all probably had
that and she looked in her book she's
like oh it means you're uncomfortable
with somebody that you're living with
or multiple people
so your your home or like your home
brain your brain of yourself that's home
doesn't feel feels vulnerable or well
she explained it to me and that was like
the month I moved into my grandpa after
my grandma died and I had never lived
with him before and I felt like well so
weird
yes it was sitting in silence
what did we talk about now
so you know what I mean so
it's very accurate and uh
my dreams are very accurate I've had
dreams of uh people I've never seen that
I've seen them in person and I remember
them from the dream
I've I've had a lot of weird
I don't know I don't know what to call
it but I have it and it's a habit my
whole life
and this stream I'm about to tell you
about is the first reoccurring dream I
ever had
and I had a conclusion and I've never
had the dream since which is kind of
insane I did a story time on this I
don't know if we've ever talked about on
here but if we have I'm sorry if we
haven't get ready if you're driving oh
you're welcome next 30 minutes is gone
for you I love stories when people
telling stories when I'm on the road I
could just space forever and listen to
everything
or I was watching Jersey Shore and
listening to Jersey Shore I gotta catch
up man I gotta catch up
I'm 12 years late I just started
watching it three months ago I've never
seen it before so I'm late all right and
all the new shit's coming out to me
anyway uh here we go
I had this dream when I was uh
three four maybe then five and seven
nine twelve fifteen then it kind of
stopped and the last time I had it was
about 16.
a photographic memory I can see
everything and remember I'm three or
four I have no record I I have no
basis to what war is I don't know these
things and I'm only telling you what I
told my mom
so three-year-old four-year-old can you
can see what that kid was thinking
that is a 9 10 year old I'm telling you
the exact same thing
nothing changing except now I know those
terms and what they are
so as three or four I remember this
story the first time I told my mom or I
was crying I remember everything about
it so it's not like I was just like yeah
and then I saw
tanks nah like I'll tell you all right
I have this dream when I was a kid the
first time I ever had it
I'm running
I'm running I have a gun
it has a sword on it
no no sorry I'm running with a gun
that's right starts off me running I'm
running I'm running I'm running I'm
running and a bunch of like
red dots are going over me
like a bunch of little red
things going over and I'm ducking and
there's a bunch of spiky wires I told my
mom barbed wire
barbed wire like there's a bunch of
spiky spiky wires
there's a bunch of barbed wire next to
me and there's like these holes like
canals like at my grandma Graces there's
a bunch of canals
and I'm running and I'm running and I'm
running and there's buildings next to me
like kind of looks like brick buildings
and they're like falling over some of
her Crush there's planes
and I see all this
little red like dots going over my head
and they're loud
and there's so much smoke in the air and
the sky's like
not blood red like
light very light light light red
Kool-Aid color
you know what I'm saying like right when
the dust starts to mix like oh it's oh
it's getting red
still like a little orange not orange
but like
so Smoky and the sky is red
and it looks clouded
but it's red I don't know how to
describe it not like shockingly cartoon
red just like realistic red still you
know what I mean
I don't know how to explain I'm a kid
I'm I just know I'm running I'm running
I'm running and there's bombs I hear
bombs going off
and then there's a park bench perfect
normal park bench not blown up
like the park bench like in The Mask
where he meets her at the park
I run and I dive and slide under it
I have my gun I slide under it and I
grab the guy with me the guy with me is
a blonde kid he's a kid
but he's like seven
at the time I had this dream I was a kid
like three or four
probably before
he's got
I can't remember what color eyes like
blue or brown
I'm trying I feel like it's like it's
meddling now like I can't remember the
color eyes now I had this dream my whole
life it's crazy
blonde hair tight curls like tight
little curly blonde hair
almost like a German kid would have
honestly
okay right like like a little Jeremy kid
in the 30s like little tight curls
shaved up here
just on the top little tight curls
blonde and he's a kid and I have him
down I'm like yeah and I and then we're
just doing this I'm holding my helmet
and there's bombs going off
and you're like [__] crumbling
and the kids with me and I'm holding him
down I'm like stay here and we're moving
and we're still under the bench we're
like looking and then I hear some guy
yelling at me I don't understand what
the hell he's saying I couldn't tell you
what he was saying but he's yelling at
me
yelling
and I turn and I have the kid behind me
I turn
and I'm like this and he has a gun and
his gun has a sword
that's what I remember telling my mom
his gun had a sword on it
long like pieceless metal stick like a
sword coming off his rifle
and I went to shoot him I'm like four
years old
having this Panic of a dream I go like
this to shoot him and it's a water gun
it's plastic and it's not even Brown
like rifle anymore it's a water gun and
I go like this
and it doesn't work like it's plastic I
can now feel it it was just metal it was
just in my hand and as I go
and I go to shoot the guy as I turn
around I'm like
and it's got colors it's a water gun
like it's a plastic grayish
[Music]
muted gray kind of white pearl colored
water gun with like orange and blue on
it like a Nerf gun doesn't have the
orange pump though
you know that doesn't have that
I don't remember looking at him like
and then he just does that the guy looks
at me he's got a green helmet oh no he's
got a green outfit or brown green outfit
green helmet like a metal
soldiers I tell my mom he has a helmet
it's like cut off it only goes right
here
not a football helmet it's not a
motorcycle helmet it's not a bike helmet
it's like a
like a cap
I don't know I don't know I described it
into my mom telling her
and as I go
he goes like that
he just goes like that like almost like
[__] you
just goes like that and I just hear and
when I hear I wake up
the stream's like
if it was a movie this dream is four and
a half minutes it's not crazy long we're
not like laying in bunkers or anything
and waiting we're not doing anything
it's just it's pretty fast
but I remember the blonde kids like
almost crying he's freaking out I'm like
stay here I got you and I'm like
um guiding him I'm guiding him
like to stay down stay down and then I
hear that [__] the whole shooting thing
I wake up [__] crying I tell my mom
had a dream again like two years later
identical and it's not like it's
different it's exactly the same I know
exactly what's gonna happen I know
exactly the guy's gonna yell at me I
know my gun's plastic all this [__] like
I know what's gonna happen I'm watching
the movie again essentially
same thing boom
nothing happens and then he goes
every time
and then he does this everybody does
this and then it goes black every single
time just goes black
and not like I see something hit me it
just goes black I don't see anything I
just see him go and I hear it goes black
so
I had that dream again I was like 10.
I had that dream again I was like 11.
and by this time I already know of the
war dream the war dream I always
remember oh the war dream
now that I'm older
you know 12 for last time I had was like
16. last time I had it I now realize
what's going on
oh those red things those are tracers
they're Tracer bullets going over my
head I think every 50th bullet
is a red one to let you know where
you're aiming
so every every red one there's 50 in
front of that which is insane to me
it's horrible
so those are bullets those dips like at
Grandma's are bunkers
spiky thinks is barbed wire those are
the trenches those are the trenches the
outfit and the way guys yelling oh this
is World War II
probably a German guy yelling at me I
couldn't remember what he was saying I
couldn't understand it but he's yelling
at me
probably German I'm assuming because I
can't understand the language whatsoever
as a kid I remember he was like barking
at me
and every time I had it when I got older
it's not like he says different [__]
it's the same same dream over and over
and over like continuously every three
to four years I'm having this Panic of a
dream
nightmare I should call it
but I always remember the buildings and
where the buildings look in the sky
behind it planes going and there was
bombs and there was hella smoke and
there's the red stuff red and the
building crushed on my right with a big
hole you can see the second floor of the
build almost like a GTR uh Call of Duty
map
really describing the way it was kind of
like a Call of Duty map honestly
so I have the dream and as I get older
I'm like oh that's a bayonet on his gun
you're probably in World War II if I can
have the dream and assess and write
these all down like well kid it sounds
like you had a World War II dream what
were you watching
I didn't watch war movies I was three or
four years old I'm watching Sonic and
like
you know X-Men I don't watch war movies
I don't want I I like war movies now but
I couldn't tell you what war movie my
mom and dad liked as a kid there is none
and if it was Full Metal Jacket it
definitely they definitely let me watch
it past private uh pass in the private
pile part my mom would have never let me
watch that as a three-year-old
so as I get older I'm like why did I
know all why did I see the [__] that
I've never seen
that's what always threw me off when I
was like 11 14. 16 having this dream
is how was I three or four having dreams
about [__] that I had never seen before
ever
so that dream stays in my head I'm down
selling packs doing my thing you know
doing you know blah blah blah still have
insane dreams
I have way more dreams maybe we'll do
another podcast about it but
I know the stream by heart I could tell
you I could put in the movie and script
I can somebody could draw it I can show
you what I saw right now
so
I know that dream about the back of my
hand I start dating Rosie Rosie's mom is
adopted right
her grandma Rosie's mom's parents well
her grandma Rosie's Grandma Grandpa are
pastors they're both pastors
Rosie's dad
his dad's a pastor so both sides
grandparents are pastors right
they have a huge house they live next
door to their own church
huge house where they'd get a bunch of
kids uh do you know those people that
actually bring in like I raise these
children I did this I oh this kid is now
this oh I helped get this person clean
the fairy tale movies is exactly what
Rosie's grandma grandpa did they weren't
sitting there taking checks to help
people they were just helping people
which is INS
I thought Rosie might have been
exaggerating she's not exaggerating at
all it's it was insane the kind of [__]
they did for Planada the City by Merced
is crazy
anyway when I met Rosie's Grandpa
he was already in a bedridden like in a
wheelchair
and then bedridden
but he's this great big ass big ass
white guy Pastor very deep voice right
very commanding voice
and uh
he has very bad dementia when I met him
so before going over there she told me
like warned me like yo he has very bad
dementia he doesn't remember well the
every the whole family like prepped me
and I went over there
completely fine guy was normal
super chill remembered everybody in the
room said everybody's name was talking
blah blah blah I left and then we got in
the car next time I went to Rosie's
mom's house they're like we don't know
what happened
like he
he was fine that was a like what a great
opportunity for you to meet him he's
like oh you're Rosie's boyfriend okay
it's like my little Rosie has a boy he's
all hyped as his grandkid and
we talked he was chill the whole time
like this is the guy that you guys were
talking like this goes off on random
[__] doesn't remember anybody freaks out
on you
what this guy was chill went over there
again a couple months ago same exact
thing
everything was fine we talked about
random [__]
watch TV
that's it he only watched pastors
that was it guys it was very
normal old man to me and everybody's
like we don't understand like that's the
second time that's happened that's crazy
anyway
um he has super bad dementia every other
time he just glossed all the time right
so just lost in his head
and Rosie's like so stoked because she's
like yo you met my grandpa like he was
chill like I didn't even think that was
ever gonna happen you know what I mean
because he is as full-blown dementia
then he gets uh a little sick and then
he has to stay in his bed more
he just he was in World War II he's a
full-blooded German
full-blooded German but fought for
America because he was born here his dad
fought in Germany 4-1-1
he's a full blooded German came over
here was like ah no that's not cool I'm
going to America then his son got
drafted which is so terrible
it's just insane right like I left
Germany for No More War I came to
America had to go back to Germany to
fight send my kid back send my child
back blonde child blonde hair blue-eyed
child
right
so and this is the craziest part about
all of it right
he does not talk about World War II he
did a whole tour over there he will not
talk about it I guess he talked to
Norma Jean is great as Rosie's Grandma
Norma Jean
uh the whitest people on Earth from the
Midwest they moved over here to be
pastors they're they were the coolest
um
he does not talk about war he do not
talk about war with him you don't bring
it up everybody knows that like you
leave it alone that's in his past he's
not like talking about that Rosie's
never talked to him about that and at
the time we're 23 24 right she's never
talked to a rap about it ever
um so we go to his bed because he's not
in the wheelchair he's like in bed now
he's like getting worse
huge guy the deepest big deep giant
voice very very deep
and uh
we go into his room and I was like kind
of like odd like should I go under the
your grandpa's room and sit with you
he's like is that cool or should I not
Rosie's like no sit with me
I go in
he's fine hey Rosie remembers are off
the bat Hey Thomas I'm like oh [__] he
remembers me oh damn let's go and we're
sitting there
for 30 seconds
it's in the middle of the day
and he goes hey
you know you remind me of somebody and I
go really he goes I didn't know who it
was but now I know who it is you remind
me of somebody
I'm like
awesome that's cool it's like who is it
and he goes
so I was in Germany he's like it's World
War II and Rosie kind of looked at me
like what the [__]
is he gonna talk about Germany right now
she kind of side-eyed me
he goes so I did a tour in Germany blah
he just starts talking about his Rank
and what he did and what he did he's
like 19 years old blah blah young kid
scared to death
he's like skinnies could be you know
doing that old man like describing
yourself
in different forms skinnies can be light
as a feather just a twig like he just
kept going like ah yeah all right
because there was this young Mexican guy
who looked just like you he's like he's
my friend he's like just like he said
his name
but I'm not gonna say his name just in
case they're like that's my grandpa
don't be talking you know what I mean
it's weird when you talk about war [__]
he's like he looked just like you and
that's why you remind me of him that's
who it is and he was like coming to like
that's who you remind me of kind of one
of those right but like very old and
deep voice and kind of sick so he he was
kind of sat up here's his bed I'm
sitting toward the foot to the left of
it and Rosie's at the head of the bed
talking to him like holding his hand and
[__] and she's looking at me like
and he goes so
one time in war the scariest time in my
life he goes straight into a full story
like
Malcolm in the Middle everything stops
light goes on him to reckon he's just
telling a story looking right at me and
he's talking to me
and I'm just like oh wow your grandpa's
talking holy [__] he's going to tell me
about war this is crazy I'm the only
person in your family the newest person
in your family not even married yeah
we've been dating barely like seven
months and he's gonna tell me to [__]
everybody else is going to be pissed or
go what how you know what I mean I
didn't even ask for it that's what I'm
thinking like wow I wonder if everyone's
gonna be cool with this
that's what I was thinking I wasn't
thinking anything like whoa War
and he goes so a little Mexican friend
he's like he's a little brown what he
was described he's like he's like look
just like you look just like a stocky
guy
um
I was like all right cool yeah we look a
lot yeah I get it
but he wasn't like being a weirdo he's
just saying like you look just like you
but he was a stocky guy anyway
he starts going into a straight
full-blown War Story guys enough to
where he started and went oh this is not
going to be fun this is going to be a
this is going to be one of those stories
he could see he's like
we get trapped and he starts going
straight into war war eyes like we got
locked down and he starts going into
full detail but like
storytelling master that he I guess he
was had no idea that this man was so
detailed
we're locked down so we're locked down
night one we don't get up because
there's too many tracers I've seen too
many people getting taken out by tracers
and I'm not gonna stand up I'm a tall
guy that's what he's like I'm a big guy
like I'm not I'm not standing up not
getting out of this bunker I'm not
getting out of the trenches I'm gonna
stay in the trench and he said me and my
buddy he stuck it out with me I was
scared to death he stuck it out with me
and he's like Knight two he's on tracers
and bombs still going off hearing people
scream he's like all I do is hope to God
that somebody comes by that we can hop
in a vehicle and get out he said he was
basically at D-Day
which is the was it Norway Beach beach
to Norway right Normandy Normandy sorry
Norway
Normandy
American American uh
learning teaching right here guys here
we go
I was probably selling drugs during that
period anyway here we go
because yeah we were locked down
he's all day two
he's like I didn't think we're gonna
make it I'm sitting there I can hear
people screaming my buddy's there he's
like we're sitting there we're just
gonna tough it out he's like I can hear
bombs going off there's planes going out
here screaming I hear tracers and I'm
not getting up and I'm like whoa what
the [__] in like my arms like you know
when you get that kind of like that like
slight shake like I got goosebumps
thinking about that [__]
and he's like
I don't know what to do I'm scared I'm
not gonna make a run for it and he goes
day three morning of he's describing
this like a movie or like 24. dink dink
dink with times and [__] date germ like
it's just crazy as [__] dude
and I'm I'm periodically looking at
Rosie but he's he's looking at me so I'm
not trying to like be rude
I'm looking back at him which is kinda
odd he's telling a story into my eyes
and like
[__]
and then
as he starts talking
the more he starts talking he's like
we're going down the trench where we're
trying to move and he's like my friends
got me he's like don't worry come with
me come with me we duck down and the
more he's talking he goes there's
tracers I can hear explosions and I go
in my head I'm like
this traces and explosions
you're a blonde kid
what and I started thinking this sounds
a lot like my [__] dream
I'm 15 minutes in this story and it just
hits me I'm like
what did you just say your homie tells
you what get down stay down come with me
okay continue I didn't say that to him
in my head I'm like
what the [__] did you just say
he's like and then what do we hear
and he said something like he did a
comparison to seeing God I can't hear
what he said so and then I saw the most
beautiful things like an ally tank
that's what he said like I see one of
our tanks and it's coming by us he's
like he's like oh we're in the trench
he's basically saying we're in the
trenches barbed wire
is that they got to get over that
and then there's a tank he's like my
friend tells me you stay down you stay
behind me come with me we're hopping on
the side of that tank and we're gonna
get out of here
he's like we've been there for three
days I haven't been walking on my leg
he's he even said like it's freezing I'm
in two feet of mud it's like my legs are
like this I was a skinny kid my legs
were like noodles it's like I'm not I
was not ready for he's a stocky guy he
can the way he was saying he was like I
was just too small I was just too like
the way he's saying like I was just too
weak to get up and he's like so he
started dragging me
so it takes about 30 yards away 30 yards
away 15 yards away and my friend says go
he grabs me we get over the barbed wire
and we start sprinting and we're using
it as cover
like we're using the tank as cover from
the turrets so he can jump on and hold
on to the side of the tank
to hope that the tank is leaving so he
could live
right like
because you can't keep up with it you're
so dying you're so tired that you can't
even keep up with it if there's a foot
soldiers they're probably going to shoot
you looking at you on the side of the
tank
so that your only chance is to hold on
the side of a tank
so he says
I'm running but I'm just so tired he's
like it's only eight yards away and I
just can't catch up to it and he's like
my friends holding me run and run he's
like all right come on come on he says
this little Mexican homie he didn't say
homie he's like my Mexican my little
friend my friend he said his name but my
friend so and he says his name he's all
he hops up easy as can be back in that
tank holding his body against the side
he's like he's right on top where the
he's explaining basically where the
track is and you know with the thing
that twists he's on the side of that
any moment
killed at any moment
but he says I see him and I'm falling
behind I can hear explosions I hear
tracers and he's like I'm that's it he's
like I can't I just can't do it I can
keep up and I'm watching my trip home
leave he's like I'm watching it go away
and he's only like a couple yards away
he says but he's like
he just can't do it so he's like
and then there's sorry I don't keep
saying and then and then
so his homies on the back of the tank
basically hand out like Aladdin do you
trust me that's how I'm imagining it
little brown guy
and he's like I just couldn't do it so I
started slowing down and he's like
without a beat he hops off the tank
runs behind me and starts pushing me
gets under my arm
we get to the tank it gets me up throws
me right on the tank he's like I'll flop
over
onto the back side of the tank he's like
I could still get shot but I'm just I'm
just like what are you gonna do he's
like I have to do something
he says he reaches out
to grab his homie to hop on he's like
his homie was easily jumping onto the
tank like yo boom put him on and then he
said he put him on reach his hand out
he's like and that's when I saw my
friend blow into pieces he saw more to
hit right behind him blew him to pieces
all over me
exactly then I went home
and that's how he ended the story Jesus
Christ
looked just like you
said you look just like you he looks
just like him
and I'm like in my head like
I was gonna die in these dreams
no because that's another dream I cried
to my dad about when I was like six
we're a truck driving I woke up freaking
out
that there wasn't like I had other War
dreams and he uh
same thing I just explained to him like
I've had dreams about explosions and
this and War but that's the one that was
always reoccurring it's word for word
step for step you look just like him
and I it didn't fully hit me until I
left and started thinking about every
word he said like
what
always have this dream and since I was a
kid I always have a dream I get shot in
the face
since I was a kid that's why I was
always so nervous about getting shot
Merced I told you about them like I
always thought I was gonna get shot by
some gang man when I was a kid
and then that fool tried to shoot me the
head but like obviously it was not
nearly severe
but yeah he said that [__] to me
we talked about nothing for like a
couple more minutes and then he was like
I'm tired so we left
and then we're in the car I'm telling
Rose like and she doesn't get it yet
either I'm like Rosie my dream she's
like what do you taught my oratory it's
like the curly-headed kid
and the thing is there's a picture of
him
standing in his uh
his outfit with the kid no all young oh
with another guy
little curls a little blonde little only
top curls um shaved up just like the
little kid I mean damn near the same
[__] haircut what do you take from
all this not even done yeah
so I think Rosie has wild dreams too but
they're more like a spiritual [__] I'm
I'm more of like yo be careful make sure
you warn this person make sure you chill
keep yourself I'm like a spidey sense
Rosie's more like message type of [__]
gotcha let's push tree's house we know
he's super sick
we go to the hospital he's in one of the
big rooms
so you know like oh there's operating
like oh he's he I mean he's like in the
big ass room with doctors
not just like a room where you lay and
get better
almost like an operating room gotcha we
go in this big [__] man
on the table
hi Rosie
you take care of her I'm like yeah man
of course you know I'm just trying to be
like the yo you're sick type of thing
right
and we used to visit with him Rosie's
sad as [__] she's obviously going
through it we're walking out Rose is in
front of me and I don't know why I look
back right through one little slit of a
window I look back and he's looking
right at me he does that
he just does that one to me
I went and I and I walked and I kept
while I stopped and I went
I just kept like kind of like a
just to be polite but the way he looked
at me like
all right
I kept walking
went to bed
um
Rosie woke up freaking out because she
had a dream
that her Grandpa
no no woke up to a phone call and Rosie
was already freaking out she said she
was having a nightmare woke up to a
phone call I already knew exactly what
happened by the looking Rose's face it
was Pitch Black I can see it wrote to a
phone call from her mom that her Grandpa
died right a couple hours after we left
which is like he died in the couple
hours after he left Rosie started
freaking out because she when she woke
up she was already like stressed out
she was having a dream that she was
talking to her Grandpa because he said
he had just passed away and he's going
to leave he's like I just want to talk
to you before I leave but I'll uh he's
talking about all this advice [__]
that's I was her to him like he would
always give her advice do like the
real ABC family [__] but like real life
stuff and he would and she's like I was
having a dream he was telling me he just
passed away and he's gonna leave right
now but he's always going to be watching
me all this [__] and then like she got
woken up by that call and it was still
crazy
all that [__] happening just like this
back to back to back to back to back it
was nuts dude
it was crazy
um but yeah that's a wild dream that
concluded at the end I've never had that
dream but then again I didn't have that
dream from 16 to 22 when I met Rose
either but like I never had that dream
again
but yeah dude that was some [__] and the
thing is when I saw the picture him in
his uniform like what the [__] he didn't
look like the kid but he had the
resemblance you know resemble like the
eyes the little the hair the skinny
little noodle kid I'm telling you dude
like I I can I can tell you exactly what
that little boy looked like he was like
seven years old
he's a cam size but I was little
like I was my age yeah but every time I
had the dream even when I was 15 I was
still a little kid the kid never got
older so strange yeah the kid never got
older and the guy that shot me was a
full-grown man
I never understood it it was like the
most vulnerable dream ever oh you're a
kid and your gun don't work
[__] you I think that's what that dream
is like the most vulnerable you could be
yeah like I can't get more more than
that dude
but yeah describing it my mom you're not
your child question your child like why
do you know what tracers look like
trenches Thomas why do you know about
trenches like I would have asked my
child what would you just say
why do you know that look like this yes
that's D-Day Thomas what the [__] and
what what I imagine was not today there
was no Beach
what I saw was not D-Day at all because
there was no Beach
there was no huge mountain with turrets
it was just like open when you see those
pictures of land Opus Mass scorched
Earth land with barbar
fool stuck in it bunch of crazy [__]
dude
oh 1917.
just like that just like that except
more people up top than in the trenches
because when I was in that trench in or
when I was a
running and [__] I didn't sell nobody in
there and just all the dips like a
grandma's little canals that I hadn't
seen anything else I'm very I'm very
specific I can't like tell you like no
actually I didn't see that no nobody I
saw nobody else on our side
dressed like my the kid that I was with
but the kid I was with was dressed a lot
like the guy that shot me
except he didn't have a helmet but but
the guy did um
I couldn't tell you if I had an element
I didn't touch my head but I just
remember with my little gun
[__] weird [__] dude
yeah there's a lot of people out there
that talk about like past life [__] with
kids and stuff like that I don't know
but it's weird that it's stuck with you
your whole life and kind of resonated
with you
yeah and the fact that it kind of like
made me think like
we met before Oh man
something happened
something happened yeah
like stuck out for a reason like yo I
hope you marry my granddaughter one day
as you just die like I hope your soul
goes and you marry my granddaughter one
day or [__] something dude it's crazy
[__] man but yeah pretty wild wild stuff
yeah
dreams crazy ass [__] story Fleetwood
Mac dreams
um yeah wild wild [__] um sorry I got
stuck every time I talk about the story
I get so stuck on it
as they're thinking about it all again
but yeah no idea I've had wild wild wild
wild [__] dreams that have
and I'll save I'll save that I have
other ones that are just
I don't know
I have one that could be so current I
don't even want to say it on here I'll
tell you after but I have a very very
very odd
wait I have talked about it
I have the reoccurring dream that I
remember said at my grandma's property
I'm looking out toward Merced there's a
bunch of spaceships
shooting at planes
and spaceships shooting red laser things
into the ground and catching on fire and
then some of the ships going
getting staticky and they're just drones
hmm
I've had that dream a lot same exact
dream in the same exact position at my
grandma's
when did that start
before right before my Rosie
very odd I've never had a recurring
dream oh man I have
I had many dreams
like I had a dream where uh I saw the
world ending and I was in San Francisco
with my friend but I couldn't see which
friend it was and I had another friend
with me which was Ryan
and there was a manhole cover I was
trying to lift it up because I saw like
a bunch of Fire coming at us I was
trying to get in the manhole cover
and I saw a bunch of people running
around where they look like zombies like
trying to attack other people
and I heard
like a speaker from the skies going you
have messed up too much and we have to
restart this one I'm very sorry guys I
was like what
and I was just running there was a bunch
of Fire
and a bunch of people trying to
like attack people
and like looting
and the ground was cracking
ha
and then I just remember it was San
Francisco and it was New Year's Eve
it's all I remember because I was like
yes New Year's let's go to San Francisco
and we're on top of a car trying to
fight off these people when my dream
ended
and then the next day this is like 2009
the next day Ralph my cousin that's with
me right now
the next day when I'm in Mercedes listen
to Santa Cruz goes hey
next week for New Year's Eve do you want
to go to San Francisco with me they're
doing it was for like a band and an
event and I go what did you just say to
me he goes there's an event in San
Francisco on New Year's Eve next week
and I go Ralph I'm gonna tell you right
now I just had a dream about San
Francisco and the world ending on New
Year's Eve and I think I'm gonna pass
and he went got to be honest bro I
totally get it if I had
I wouldn't be doing that either I had
that dream I'm not saying anything
happened but it definitely made me go
nah
I'm good because what happens when it
starts happening I'm gonna go
all he had to do was listen to your
instincts stupid
I have a lot of dumb dreams guys a lot
of dumb weird dreams
but there's only been a few times I
actually saved my ass twice where they
saved my ass and we'll get into those in
another day because I think uh
this will turn into six hours for real
it'll turn into too long and as we do
this side camera Marty's totally not
changing the battery
he's just break dancing
you hear that
that was the Rope he was doing a robot
power down
um
damn yeah okay yeah that's that's we had
to talk about today I uh don't remember
anything else of going on with Earth uh
threw my back out and oh that's what
I'll talk about I threw my back out as I
told you I was working with the trainer
and went do a full lunge bro I bet you
could do full lunges on that leg and I
did I heard something go I've just been
hurt ever since
so what I did was I laid down from
Saturday night to Wednesday morning I
laid down either on my bed with a
heating pad or floating in my bathtub
for four hour sessions in the bathtub
which was crazy but you know what I did
do
I used YouTube remember how I say I
don't use YouTuber I just watch fight
clips
stupid people getting hurt I used
YouTube uh actually I want to say the
guy's name because I think he does that
good of a job that we really need I need
to say his name
let me make sure let me make sure
his name how do you go subscriptions
there are subscriptions
that's not good
come on buddy what's his name
or did I follow him on the wrong Channel
no I had to have
um he does podcast there it is comedy
enforcement
this guy you seen this guy
oh yeah yeah I've seen it before great
job comedy enforcement oh he does such a
good job and also he made so many videos
before he hit 20K I watched 900 videos
in a row because guys we're just about
to 20K I was like damn well how many
videos do you do but each time he was
gaining followers but it was just so
wild because I watched him so
consecutively in one night oh yeah that
I'm like
already
this is too good content for him not to
have 20 what I was just kind of shocked
like you said 20K 10 times in a row
people really aren't following
but this is great content anyway I did
not know about podcast beef
Marty knew because Marty's into
podcasting before he met me obviously
and actively knows
sorry one second
I had no idea you ready
sorry
Adam 22.
an A.D we had a d on our show two weeks
ago sorry
I know he used to be a no jumper
I know he left no jumper just clip this
Marty
I do podcasting
I do YouTube
I live in Los Angeles
and I knew none of the stuff
I'm in all the same fields and knew
nothing
sorry
there we go
dry his throat
what I mean by that guys ready here's
your clip smarty A.D out of 22. I knew
they don't like each other I knew he
used to be on no jumper no idea why they
left I didn't watch any of the stuff I
just
continued with my life
right never watching I didn't take the
time to sit as I said I don't use
YouTube right I don't watch other
podcasts I don't watch other YouTubers I
just
exist on YouTube and I watch stupid
clips of fights and Street beefs
so
I didn't know why Adam 22 and 80 don't
like each other
no idea
had ad on the channel or on the show
booked him a week out the night before
12 hours before he comes on our show
he apparently goes on a live and goes at
Adam 22. nine minutes before we start
Marty goes you see that [__] last night
I go what he goes I guess ad went on
live we really went high for real
right before he comes up it looks like
we're trying to initiate and start beef
with everybody
it's not a big deal could happen to
anybody right Could Happen didn't know
we had milk 74 on the show
act did not know he was actively beefing
with Adam 22. remember that remember
right before 30 minutes before he got
here we're looking at [__] like oh him
and I don't like each other he goes they
do not like each other at all
[Music]
I hope we don't talk about that and we
didn't
um
but if I'm over there no joke I'm like
hey this dope as usual shows really
likes to interview people that we're
beefing with as for being with them like
I promise you it's not bad
so what I'm saying is A.D was on the
show through my back out that Sunday
what did I do
I sat there and I the clip came up
and it said A.D and I went oh Community
fig Community I need to watch more of it
I just had him on the show let me just
dip my toe into it the first thing was
like goes off and answer my way oh
my you know my back hurts I'm not
filming
I pressed play
never do that on YouTube [__] I just
watch stupid random stuff
10 minutes into the video I go nope I
have to figure I have to know what
happened so I found another's channel
that breaks it all down and goes so this
is what's going on I go perfect go and
it breaks down the beef and I'm like oh
okay so you guys are just mad at each
other all right I get it I understand
you got a friend somewhere
I had no idea why they were mad who was
mad at who and for what no reason I
don't really understand all the details
but I had them on the show yeah and
still didn't know until that weekend I
went I really should start
figuring out who does what and what
field
who is what the other day I'm live my
friends like bought me something
something I'm like I don't know who that
is he's like you're a [__] hater I'll
go
I'm sorry who was like she's a podcast
She interviewed Drake and go oh the
white chick that was rude to everybody
she just seems like she's like trying to
get everybody on their toes it's kind of
like a between uh Two Ferns is that Zach
galvanakis between two firsts yeah yeah
it kind of feels like that like you're
trying to catch him off their toes I'm
like oh I've never I don't watch her
[__]
and I'm like oh I kind of sound like a
hater who's that yeah I kind of did but
I genuinely who is that I don't know
[__] sorry
I should probably start learning more
things about stuff so with that being
said comedy enforcement oh I took a
[__]
high dive
into this [__] I found out about the all
the tiger belly stuff
oh yes oh I can't get it wrapped up and
drama him and his wife split yup Clara
kalila
I'm in no position to talk about any of
these people you know I can say whatever
I want I don't think I don't really like
her okay
I think she's kind of manipulative and
not very nice
but actually seemed like a nice person
is that [__] up
I mean not after what we talked about
your aunt you know like no no no no no
because all the clips I'm watching I'm
like
I watched all those and then I'm like oh
they broke up
I don't know any of these things
yeah so my oh they're broke up oh wow
and all this stuff's coming I'm like
you guys don't seem like you you should
be together oh they're broken up oh it
makes sense now but I was like why is
she down there for so long that's kind
of sad I'd be sad if I was Bobby like
even if I don't want to be with you
we're still [__] homies it's weird
they still do the show together yeah and
they still do the show together but as I
was watching everything in the comedy
enforcement everybody breaks it down I
guess it's like an ongoing thing more
people think of this stuff
Reddit I should hop on Reddit apparently
that's where all this stuff spartaned
Reddit is just a bunch of Blue Links to
me and they're very confusing it looks
like a page when you click it it goes
URL 407.
that's what it looks like dude or when
like your computer used to start in 1996
and it flood a bunch of code that's what
Reddit looks like to me it's so hard to
figure out
I should get on it because the guys
Reddit thread started this talking about
the Bobby Lee stuff I didn't know the
breaking up I didn't know that he was
doing whatever he was and she was
whatever they were doing to each other I
had no idea still like Bobby Lee he's
awesome I didn't know about that beef I
didn't know about the bread and Shop
Brian Callan
uh uh uh Reddit conspiracy thing I
didn't I didn't know what shopisms were
I didn't know Brendan Chavez so hated I
didn't know I did I've heard some of it
you know we've talked about some of it
together yeah like oh damn people are
really going hard on him huh now it goes
a lot deeper than that Thomas like
there's a lot the whole thing about it
like really
now I know yeah
Reddit kind of police's YouTube whoa
yeah so this is what I'll say
everybody's real mean to him I feel so
bad if I was him everybody's so mean to
that man oh my God whether I don't care
like we said earlier she did this she
did that still feel bad she her legs
broken and all her kids are walking
around her that's what it is like with
the Brennan Shawn thing like yo
don't listen to his stuff then you guys
are really making fun of the guy but
also like I don't
I have no say I have one week of knowing
the knowledge I have one week I wasn't
there for all the like and once again he
proves himself to be a jerk and once
again he proves himself to development
I'm like wow damn you guys really watch
podcasts I did not know all of that I
didn't know Brian Callum Bobby Lee are
friends anymore that was a big one I
didn't know about uh Bert Kreischer uh I
did there was a bunch of stuff about
that Andrew Schultz uh with Whitney
Cummings on the show it's like the most
awkward stuff in podcasting I don't it
started with Brendan and it overflowed
so much from Brendan and started to
spill out onto the other comedians
basically
yeah well now you actually asked me if I
was The Mastermind behind this the other
day guys I genuinely Marty was sitting
there after I watched all this stuff
right away I need you to tell me be
honest
it's okay just be honest it would have
made sense I think
not at all you're the one behind the
fighter in the kid room
because Marty started with them with the
whole show see episode one yeah worked
with them behind the scenes did
everything all their stuff
and then we won't say but like
you weren't like going the coolest
fashion
it was time to move on
it's like this like damn dude this
sandwich damn dude I'm so full of the
sandwich
I just want to throw it away hey I'm
gonna take that sandwich from you
I didn't want it anyway but I don't want
you to be the one that takes my sandwich
I want to throw away that [__] if I want
to throw it away don't fire me I'll quit
damn I almost threw that launch that
[__] up but the way anyway the way you
got you're like it was time to go away
from the show and do our own thing yeah
I get that but it's more like
I don't think we ever talk about it's
more like yo
I know you've been working in there for
a long time I hope this text is
sufficient
yeah yeah like that well that's text let
me go
home well yeah no but that I get it but
I'm not saying like we have beef and not
at all the freaking Brown was on here I
think Apple's hilarious yeah what I'm
saying is I didn't know that people
didn't like that man like that yeah
there's a bunch of other communities
like Carlson see it Rogan [__] I am very
late
I am talking about a 15 year old thing I
knew that carlsman c was a joke Thief if
I knew that I knew that Rogan called him
out on stage I get that I've seen that
clip on YouTube before I had no idea who
was about what it's about I didn't know
Ari shaffir beat the dog shadow Bobby
Lee multiple times I didn't know any of
these things I didn't know anything I
didn't know Bobby Lee was on camera yeah
yeah he steals and that's what kind of
sealed the deal for Carlos Mencia I
didn't know any of this I didn't you
know Marshall yeah but I didn't know
about podcast beef dude I promise you we
won't have that here okay but I just go
home
same don't care don't care enough at all
but you know what cause you know what
the problem was how this all started
in my opinion
it was about being out of touch with the
fans in the sense that because like when
I on on the sense of like on Brendan's
part oh so I know who you talking about
yeah like that's how it started because
in the same when I met you and I'm like
you answer thousands of comments
hmm that's a vastly different approach
than all of my other clients have with
their comments I can I remember thinking
that right away because they had the
attitude of like [__] losers are in
the [__] comments who the [__]
comments you're gonna be a [__] but it's
like these are the fans
and that to me is what started the
negative turn because and then from
there it became just like uh
self-awareness kind of thing where they
were like waiting for them to be like no
we matter we're the fans
that's where the turn happened oh
see
everyone that in that and that DM that
Twitter or that Reddit watch this unfold
and the real opinions change in real
time so I'm coming here after facto you
guys are broom you're mean to this guy
but I don't know like that's what I said
but I've only had this information for a
week
I've only had it for a week when I was
when we first started those first couple
years it was very similar to you your
relationship with the fans and that like
it was very dialed in it was very
organic and growing and just
super positive and awesome
you know like it was awesome like it was
really cool to watch they were like
innovating in a lot of ways and like
going on tour and
you know with the rise of the UFC and
[__] yeah but I they just uh I think
yeah it's that the Crux of what I just
mentioned was just like something as
simple as the comments or just like the
self-awareness around the relationship
and the dialogue and the authenticity
with the fans how important that is how
vital it is you know there's a lot that
I learned watching a lot of the people
that I came up working for what they did
right what they did wrong that obviously
you want to learn from and avoid or do
I gotta be honest
while I was watching these there's a
documentary on this guy oh there's that
was a multiple [__] documentary oh
man that was like wow dude that's sad
people really don't like you that's not
no matter what Mr Burns still goes to
bed like damn people really don't like
me
I still feel bad yeah you know like you
still gotta feel bad for the guy
just me I do no matter what who it is
like I said that's why I was still
friends with my mom when I was like I
don't [__] with you I still feel bad for
you though because if people don't [__]
with you
that's sad you know what I mean like
this is sad fact damn no one
like that's not cool dude that's not
cool so
um even in Grandma's Boy JP the robot
still had feelings you know what I'm
saying like even though he was being a
jerk to people
still has feelings and [__] and that's
sad uh like I said I always think of
people as the kid version themselves and
they don't want to be mean to the kid
just leave him out sad
um anyway
holy [__] I had no idea I watched a lot
of podcast beef also I watched a clip
of Andrew Schultz
flagrant
apparently Bert Chrysler is afraid of
balloons and clowns
I watched a clip where they bring a
clown and a balloon
the second
you that they bring them out you see
Bert Crashers face change to a face
you've never seen
a little more self-awareness on the part
of that show
you should have cut the clown four
seconds in the second you saw his face
go from Bert Kreischer to
um
no I would have stopped it immediately
I think so but I can see on his face
like oh no no no no no that's a that's a
that's a kid mechanism like a
like that was like true fear that was
fear like that wasn't cool you could
tell the look on his face he looked like
that [__] was this is no longer like a
fun thing not fun yeah sorry I'm I'm
talking about the podcast stuff I
watched but yes I've watched it what a
sick uh YouTube channel to they break
down every single thing you can think of
I had no idea about any of it
um I need to watch more shows
um I don't know anybody
it only took almost becoming paralyzed
for a week Divine tap him well no I
could work yeah I couldn't do anything
so I was like weird like you were first
time since I've known you aware you were
done out of commission done
but I was laying in the bathtub with my
with my uh laptop on the wood thing
watching this fool just letting it play
not even clicking it because I'm like Oh
my bag just let it play and it was
plugged in oh man come on
yeah people there's people that just
have kind of dedicated their channels to
like
reviewing podcasts people's activities
and [__] yeah I just look around and see
some of the biggest shows I'm like hey
man
we can be there we can do that we gotta
let YouTube Let us let up on us but also
I get it
you don't hear Bad friends tigerbelly
and our bad friends Bobby Lee and Andrew
Santino was talking about meth heads
every episode
sorry and they're not saying hard hard
cuss words like this they might just
cuts but we're like you could feel it
like if you have headphones on you'll
hear [__] yeah that kind of hurt my ears
it kind of like pop the air into my ears
Turn My Headphones Up turn them shits up
all right
guys you've been here for three hours
doesn't even feel like it Marty and you
know what's crazy
my back is not doing this
all right that's what's working
I have 29 more sessions on that machine
for them to fully take my disc out and
pop them back into place
wow
I slightly fell asleep in the MRI
machine
sure yeah it's not easy to do I don't
think see I'm not claustrophobic at all
I'm the opposite of claustrophobic dude
if I sleep and Rosie's not with me like
when I slept in Vegas at my friend's
bachelor party I could I I look like a
monster sleeping I tucked the blankets
under my feet around my legs like a
coffin like a sarcophagus like like a
mummy I wrap it completely fine you can
see the whole curve of my entire body I
wrap it under my arms under my head and
then I kind of stretch it out oh my God
I gotta stretch it out and there's like
that tightness above me and it looks
like a coffin like a mummy when I I do
it because I don't know why I like
pressing that and the tension that it
holds my head and it's kind of like I'm
in a hammock okay I don't wake up like
that I'm obviously oh yeah moved but
like that's how I fall asleep I sleep on
the complete edge of the bed
on the edge of the bed with the fan
directly blasting
[__] every time
stop I could have a single size bed I
wouldn't know the difference
I don't move that's it
foreign
okay that's cool
there's other people out there doing
that [__] let me know I sleep on the
edge of the bed as if I grew up with
nine brothers yeah right
yeah single child over here
squish to the edge of the bed so it's
all about that [__] fan I wake up I
go hit the office first thing fan goes
back on oh [__]
oh [__] yeah no I sleep as as if I'm a
mummy that's crazy it's fun
too by the way
sleep because look no because you have
the blanket
and you have your feet holding it so
there's like a yeah space this high
I am on my phone under there if I want
to be oh okay you're in a it's like a
tent a fort a fort but only around my I
can look down and see my my foot my body
and blankets so tight around me and then
you could do this too
with your elbows because it's so tight
kind of like like a tent yeah
like a pot
fall asleep in that [__]
meth all right here we go guys that's it
we that's enough that's enough that's
enough that's enough oh for the first
time in a long time we have three ads in
this episode [__] yeah thank you guys
shout out to us raw ever this month
for sponsoring the show from here on out
thank you very much raw in this episode
we also have freeze pipes thank you for
freeze pipe the first sponsored video I
ever did on the open Jewel Channel ever
yeah let's go first video I ever did I
had an intro had a logo coming in and
sound
that's crazy never done any of that
before
um and [__] man escaped yeah
and then we have manscape our longest
sponsor ever thank you very much we have
a lot of big sponsors starting in
September
all right and then after this next week
is we got yeah after
[__] we got one more episode after this
comes out in between the fluffy episode
two weeks out another way of saying
let's go two weeks to fluffy guys I'm
excited I really really really really
hope I get that man
extremely hot that's a given that's
happening
he could not smoke when he's gonna get
extremely high yeah but he's fluffy we
should have big joints yes yeah
cigar style joints agreed
all right good [__] guys thank you so
much for being here Marty is there
anything else you want to add just
appreciate you guys across the board
thanks for supporting all the channels
everything guys thanks for all the nice
messages and nice comments supporting
the sponsors watching the Clips Channel
following on all the pages you guys are
the [__] we're gonna keep a
[__] pushing
yeah like that
we need tech decks too by the way yeah
we do need some tech decks for everybody
driving I've been uh I just hit a solid
kickflip
um guys thank you so much for being here
uh this has been the dope as usual
podcast we we talked about a bunch of
wild [__] today
deceit deception betrayal deceit
deception betrayal
shut up shut up Rick go break your leg
[__] was insane
that [__] was pretty wild actually party
did not stop
that's the craziest part about all of it
um yeah all right guys I don't know how
we got this far I feel like this thing
is wrong
I don't [__] know three hours we just
did my back doesn't even hurt this is
insane I love starting in the morning
look how tired UFC then watch these
[__] bills and power it at this
thing yeah yeah guys thank you so much
for being here uh shout out to all of
our sponsors shout out to you also thank
you so much for being here the dope dope
as
usualpodcast.com dope as
usualpodcast.com you can get our merch
there you can get every single piece of
information you get our write-ups
we look we look super professional you
see the Ted Talk stuff there you can see
every sponsor we've ever worked with and
if any sponsors are out there there is a
link in there for every single question
you can think of sponsorships and a form
you can fill out if you want to be a
sponsor there's no back and forth you
tell us exactly what you want exactly
every single thing I know this one dude
that made the site and he went hard on
it it's this guy
this is [__] music to my ears you got
business side of this thing this new
site that we have just really makes life
a lot easier so
so much better oh and since you know
this our our channel is not you know
getting very recommended right now
dope as usual podcast clips on YouTube
please go subscribe even if you're not
gonna watch them go like all the videos
that would really help us out like we
said we got a little swindled a little
bit so we need to
a couple thousand more watch time hours
on clips
that would really helpful that's crazy
he's like yo I need to fill this bucket
well here's a dropper
[Laughter]
but if we have 1500 homies with droppers
you know name to you watching that would
help
all right ready that's it nice shirt
I agree one of my favorite shirts it's
basically The Giving Tree but it's hug
trees with a little bong I love the
little bog and the signature is Michelle
Silverstein just I'm sorry Shell service
team supposed to be mimicked love it and
that's either Marty or Caillou
this one's kind of you that one's
Caillou yeah
guys thank you so much for being here
really appreciate you from Marty and I
this has been the dopes usual podcast
have a dope ass day oh my God
I can't believe that was three hours
three hours
[Music]
all right